This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever been frustrated with someone who never seems to change their behavior? You remind your partner, again, not to leave dirty dishes in the sink. You've had this conversation before. Maybe you snap at them. Maybe you roll your eyes and do it yourself. Or maybe you get frustrated and throw up your hands. Or maybe it's your child who melts down in the middle of the grocery store or a co-worker who fails to meet deadlines in spite of endless reminders.
这里是“隐藏大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你是否曾对那些似乎永远不会改变行为的人感到沮丧？你再次提醒你的伴侣不要把脏盘子留在水槽里。你们已经谈过这件事了。也许你对他们发火了。也许你翻了个白眼，然后自己去做了。或者你感到沮丧，双手一摊。或者也许是你的孩子在杂货铺中央大发脾气，又或者是某个同事在无数次提醒下仍然无法按时完成工作。
No matter how many times we bring it up or how many strategies we try, nothing gets them to change. Before long, resentment sets in. The temptation is to push harder. More reminders, more rules, more consequences. We tell ourselves they must be stubborn, defiant, oppositional. This week on Hidden Brain, research that explains why the techniques we use to get people to change their behavior are often strikingly ineffective.
无论我们提起多少次，或者尝试了多少种策略，没有任何办法能让他们改变。不久之后，怨恨就开始滋生。人们往往会忍不住采取更严厉的手段。更多的提醒，更多的规则，更多的后果。我们告诉自己，他们一定很顽固、叛逆、对抗。本周的“隐藏大脑”将通过研究来解释，为什么我们用来试图改变他人行为的技术往往效果惊人地差。
And we look at better ways to help the people we care about make lasting change. It can be frustrating when people do things we don't want them to. A friend cancels plans at the last minute. A loud co-worker dominates every meeting. A child refuses to get dressed for school. What goes through our minds in those moments? And how do our mindsets affect our ability to influence others to change? At Harvard Medical School, psychologist Stuart Ablon studies the science of helping people change.
我们将探讨更好的方法，来帮助我们在乎的人做出持久的改变。当人们做我们不希望他们做的事时，确实会让人感到沮丧。朋友在最后时刻取消了计划。一个声音嘈杂的同事在每次会议上都独揽话语权。孩子拒绝穿好衣服去上学。在这些时刻，我们的脑海里在想些什么？我们的心态又如何影响我们引导他人改变的能力？在哈佛医学院，心理学家斯图尔特·阿布伦专门研究帮助人们改变的科学。
Stuart Ablon, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much. It's a pleasure to be here. I appreciate you having me. Stuart, you first became interested in psychology during your senior year of high school. You got a job working with kids. Tell me about the work you were doing. Yeah, in high school, one of my first, you know, more serious jobs was working on an inpatient psychiatry unit for kids and adolescents.
斯图尔特·阿布伦，欢迎来到“隐藏大脑”。非常感谢。很高兴能来到这里。谢谢你邀请我。斯图尔特，你最早对心理学产生兴趣是在你高中最后一年。你当时得到了一份和孩子们一起工作的工作。能跟我讲讲你当时做的是什么工作吗？是的，在高中时，我的第一份、也是相对更严肃的工作之一，是在一家儿童和青少年住院精神病房工作。
So this is where kids and adolescents go when their behaviors really out of control and they are at risk of hurting themselves. someone else and they're usually admitted against their will. And I had an internship there really and I had no idea what to expect. And I remember on my first day, I was supervising along with some other staff, kids out on the playground. And this young man started to get upset, really frustrated and lose his cool. And he could tell I was the new person. And he said all kinds of awful things to me and went to try to attack me, really. And he spat in my face and he kicked me where you don't want to be kicked. And I was incredibly taken aback. And one of the sort of more senior staff members approached quickly to rescue me. And he said, let me show you how this is done
所以，这里是儿童和青少年在行为彻底失控、有伤害自己或他人的风险时去的地方，他们通常是在违背意愿的情况下被收治的。我在那里实习，当时完全不知道会发生什么。我记得在第一天，我和其他一些员工一起在操场上监管孩子们。这个年轻人开始感到不安、非常沮丧，并失去了冷静。他能看出我是新来的。他对我说了很多难听的话，并试图袭击我。他朝我脸上吐口水，还在你绝对不想挨踢的地方踢了我一脚。我惊呆了。其中一位资深员工迅速过来解救我，他对我说，让我来教你这里是怎么做的。
here. And he sort of grabbed this young man and wheeled him around and wrapped his arm around him and sort of like a what we call a physical hold, a restraint, so that he couldn't spit at him or he couldn't, you know, kick him and things like that. And this was my first on-the-job training about how to perform a physical restraint. I mean, you must have been 16 or 17 years old at the time, and the kid couldn't have been much younger than you. It's a very good point. I forget whether I was 17 or may have just turned 18. I mean, but be honest, I'm actually getting goosebumps talking about it, even though I've talked about it a lot, because it was awful. So you head home that evening.
接着他抓住这个年轻人，把他转过身去，用手臂缠住他，这是一种我们称之为物理控制或约束的方法，这样他就不能吐口水，也不能踢人了之类。这是我关于如何实施物理约束的第一堂在职培训课。我的意思是，你当时一定只有16或17岁，而那个孩子也大不了你多少。这是一个很好的观点。我忘了我当时是17岁还是刚满18岁。说实话，现在谈起它我甚至还起鸡皮疙瘩，尽管我已经谈过很多次了，因为那太可怕了。所以那天晚上你回家了。
The next day, I understand you run into this young man again. His name is Jason. What happens to it? I was particularly on guard as I passed by the room where Jason was and nervous. And he called out to me. I remember I was trying to walk by pretty swiftly, actually, so I wouldn't have to engage with him for fear of what might happen. And he called my name and I sort of turned around and I looked at him and he looked at me. And he said to me, hey, I'm sorry.
第二天，我听说你又遇到了这个年轻人。他叫杰森。后来怎么样了？当我经过杰森所在的房间时，我格外警惕，而且很紧张。他叫住了我。我记得当时其实正试图快步走过去，这样就不用和他打交道了，因为害怕会发生什么。他叫了我的名字，我转过身看着他，他也看着我。他对我说，嘿，我很抱歉。
I'm sorry about what I said. I really didn't mean it. I just lose control like that. And I don't even know what I'm saying. And I just looked at him and I said, okay, it's all right. I accept your apology. It's okay. What went through your mind at that point, Stuart?
我为我所说的话道歉。我真的不是故意的。我只是那样失去了控制。我甚至不知道自己在说些什么。我看着他说道，好吧，没关系。我接受你的道歉。没关系。斯图尔特，那个时候你心里在想什么？
Because in some ways, it was not just surprising, but I think in some ways it was also revelatory what happened in that moment. Yeah, what went through my mind again. I mean, just retelling this, Shankar, I'm emotional. just retelling it because, you know, this kid I had this horrific interaction with and he said these awful things to me and I was trying to avoid him as soon as I arrived and he's apologized to me. Clearly, this kid deeply regretted his behavior and this was just one tiny instance. I can only imagine what had gone on to get him to this inpatient psychiatry unit in the first
因为在某种程度上，这不仅令人惊讶，而且我认为在某种程度上，那一刻发生的事也是极具启发性的。是的，我心里想的……尚卡尔，光是重新讲述这件事，我情绪就很激动。仅仅是重述它，因为，你知道的，这个孩子曾和我发生过如此可怕的互动，他说过那些难听的话，而我一到那里就试图躲着他，但他却向我道歉了。显然，这个孩子对自己的行为深感后悔，而这只是其中极其微小的一个实例。我只能想象，究竟经历了什么，才让他最终来到这个住院精神病房。
place. And here he is clearly feeling terribly about this behavior, which as he's explained to me, you know, he just can't control. So you eventually become a clinical psychologist, and some years later you're interviewing another young man who is in a correctional facility. Tell me the story. What was he in for? So this young man was in for attempted murder. he had shot someone. And, you know, I had next to no experience working in correctional facilities. So it's sort of, frankly, while I had the credentials at that point, it felt pretty similar
而在这里，他显然对自己的这种行为感到极其糟糕，正如他向我解释的那样，他只是无法控制。所以你最终成为了一名临床心理学家，几年后你在一个惩教所里采访了另一个年轻人。给我讲讲这个故事吧。他因为什么进来的？这个年轻人是因为谋杀未遂进来的。他枪击了某个人。而且，你知道的，我几乎没有任何在惩教所工作的经验。所以坦白说，尽管那时我拥有专业资质，但这感觉跟当年与杰森的互动相当类似。
to that interaction with Jason. And I remember sitting very close across a bench from him. So our faces were pretty close to each other. And I asked him, I said, you know, if you don't mind, would you mind? telling me like what you were thinking when you did this. And I'll never forget this because he leaned in real close to me. And he said to me, that is the stupidest question anybody's ever asked me. And one thing I can say about myself is I don't tend to be particularly defensive. So I said to him, you know, that might be right. That might be the
我记得自己离他坐得很近，隔着一张长凳，所以我们的脸靠得很近。我问他，我说，如果你不介意的话，能告诉我你当时做这件事的时候在想什么吗？我永远不会忘记这一点，因为他把身子向前倾，离我非常近。他对我说，这是任何人问过的最愚蠢的问题。关于我自己，我可以说的一点是，我通常不是特别具有防备心理。所以我对他说，你知道，这可能是对的。这可能是
stupidest question anybody's ever asked you, but do you mind telling me why that's such a stupid question? And he looked at me and he leaned in even closer and he said, do you think if I was thinking I would have done that, you moron? And I remember thinking myself, Yeah, of course. That is the stupidest questions anybody's ever asked. Because why would he do this if he were thinking? To me, that was an important moment and reminded me, honestly, of, you know, in graduate school, we learned about aggressive responses and the difference between proactive aggression and reactive aggression.
任何人问过你的最愚蠢的问题，但你介意告诉我为什么这是一个如此愚蠢的问题吗？他看着我，把身子倾得更近了，说道：你觉得如果我在思考的话，我还会那样做吗，你这个笨蛋？我记得当时心里想，是的，当然。那确实是任何人问过的最愚蠢的问题。因为如果他在思考，他怎么会做这种事？对我来说，那是一个重要的时刻，老实说，它让我想起了我们在研究生学到的关于攻击性反应的知识，以及主动攻击和反应性攻击的区别。
And most people think that horribly aggressive acts are like planned acts where the vast majority, of them are poor responses to frustration and not thinking things through. You know, many years ago, I remember speaking with some researchers who are doing work in Chicago, and there was this sociologist Harold Pollock at the University of Chicago. He looked through all the homicide cases that he could find in the city and then looked at what led to the homicide. And again, his belief was that homicides happened because of premeditated gang violence. But what he found was very much what you're talking about, Stuart, which is there were interactions that went wrong. People lost their tempers. Things escalated. Someone had
大多数人认为可怕的攻击行为就像是有计划的行为，然而绝大多数这类行为其实是对挫折感的不良反应，根本没有经过深思熟虑。你知道，许多年前，我记得和一些在芝加哥开展研究的研究人员交谈过，芝加哥大学有一位社会学家叫哈罗德·波洛克。他查阅了他在该市能找到的所有凶杀案卷宗，然后研究是什么导致了凶杀。同样，他原本的信念是凶杀案的发生是由于有预谋的帮派暴力。但他发现的情况和你在谈论的非常相似，斯图尔特，那就是有些互动出了问题。人们失去了理智。事情升级了。有人
access to a gun and someone got shot. And over and over, what he found was that if people could pause, take a deep breath, and count a 10, it could mean the difference between a regular life and spending the rest of your life in prison. Yes. That's impulse control. Literally, the definition of impulse control is taking a few seconds to think about the likely consequences of your actions before you act. And I always tell people, you know, if we didn't have that, we humans, if we didn't have impulse control, if we just did the first thing that came to our mind,
能够拿到枪，然后就有人中枪了。他一次又一次地发现，如果人们能够暂停一下，深呼吸，从一数到十，这可能就意味着正常生活与在监狱度过余生之间的区别。是的。这就是冲动控制。字面意思上，冲动控制的定义就是在你采取行动之前，花几秒钟思考一下你的行为可能带来的后果。我总是对人们说，你知道，如果我们没有这个能力，我们人类，如果我们没有冲动控制能力，如果我们只是去做脑海中浮现的第一件事，
said the first thing that came to our mind, the world would be an ugly place. I usually tell people, if you want to do a little experiment, go through a day where you imagine you did or said the first thing that came to your mind throughout the course of the day. You'll amuse yourself, but you'll also be horrified. about what the world would be like. When people do bad things,
说出脑海中浮现的第一件事，这个世界就会变得面目全非。我通常会告诉人们，如果你想做一个小实验，不妨想象这样一天：在这一天里，你做了或说出了全天脑海中浮现的第一件事。你会觉得好笑，但同时也会对这个世界的模样感到震惊。当人们做了坏事时，
we often think it's because they're bad people, or they're being stubborn, or they're simply not trying hard enough. We attempt to help them fix this behavior through rewards and punishments, or we just encourage them to try harder. When we come back, a psychological insight into a better way. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
我们常常认为那是因为他们是坏人，或者他们很顽固，又或者他们根本不够努力。我们试图通过奖励和惩罚来帮他们修正这种行为，或者我们只是鼓励他们加倍努力。稍后回来，我们将为您带来对更好方法的心理学洞察。你正在收听的是“隐藏大脑”。
I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's easy to believe that our behavior is a matter of incentives. If I want to be healthy, I'll get some exercise. If I want to get more done at work or school, I'll stop playing video games or watching so much TV. When people act in certain ways or misbehave in certain ways, we feel it's because those are choices they are making.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是“隐藏大脑”。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们很容易相信，我们的行为完全取决于诱因。如果我想保持健康，我就会去锻炼。如果我想在工作或学校里完成更多任务，我就会停止玩电子游戏或看那么多电视。当人们以某种特定方式行事或有某种不良行为时，我们会觉得那是他们自己做出的选择。
At Harvard Medical School, psychologist Stuart Ablon has tested the veracity of this belief. Stuart, early in your career, you began working with a psychologist, Ross Green, he was developing a new approach to treating children with behavior problems. Tell me a little bit about what you did together. Yes, I had the good fortune of coming for my postdoctoral fellowship at Mass General Hospital and the Department of Psychiatry there.
在哈佛医学院，心理学家斯图尔特·阿布伦对这种信念的真实性进行了检验。斯图尔特，在你的职业生涯早期，你开始与心理学家罗斯·格林合作，他当时正在开发一种治疗有行为问题儿童的新方法。请跟我讲讲你们是一起做了些什么。是的，我有幸来到麻省总医院及其精神病学部进行博士后研究。
And he was just getting started there as well. And he was my clinical supervisor for a year or so. And then we went on to work together for about 10 years. And what he was writing about, as he was writing this book, The Explosive Child, is decades of research that had shown that kids with very challenging explosive behavior that they struggled in certain areas of what we call neurocognitive skill or thinking skills. And so he was putting these ideas out there that the way I talk about it is that these kids seem to lack skill. rather than will. Which was a bit of a revelation when you think of how we tend to respond to challenging behavior because it all revolves around trying to motivate people to behave better,
他当时也刚在那里开始工作。他做我大约一年的临床导师，之后我们继续合作了大约10年。正如他在其著作《易怒的孩子》中所写的那样，数十年的研究表明，具有极具挑战性的易怒行为的孩子，在所谓的神经认知技能或思考技能的某些领域存在困难。因此，他提出了这些观点，用我的话来表达就是：这些孩子似乎缺乏技能，而不是缺乏意志。
safe in the assumption that the reason they're not behaving well is because they lack the motivation to do so. I want to drill down into this because I think this is such a pervasive belief, which is that when we're trying to change someone and they don't change, almost automatically the thought comes to our mind. This person knows what they need to do. They know what's going to be good for them to do. They've agreed that it's the good thing for them to do,
这真是一个启发性的发现，当你想到我们通常如何回应具有挑战性的行为时，因为这一切都围绕着试图激励人们表现得更好，
and they're not doing it. Clearly, it's a lack of will. Yeah, absolutely. And I think one of the main reasons, though, that that thought kicks in for us so quickly is it's really aggravating when people don't do what we want them to do, whether that's, you know, our child, our partner, our colleague, you name it, we get frustrated. And when we're frustrated, we humans don't tend to have as good access to the smart part of our
确信他们表现不佳的原因是因为缺乏这样做的动机。我想深入探讨这一点，因为我认为这是一种根深蒂固的信念，那就是当我们试图改变某个人而他们没有改变时，几乎会自动地在脑海中冒出一个想法。这个人知道他们需要做什么。他们知道这样做对他们有好处。他们已经同意这是对他们有好处的事，
brain. And frankly, we sort of reach very quickly for power and control to try to restabilize things. So, you know, I think that's part of the reason. We've sort of long believed this. There's sort of a conventional wisdom around this, that motivation, that behavior is all about motivation. But then you layer on top when people don't do what we want them to do or do things we don't want them to do, it frustrates us. It triggers us. And that makes it hard for us to have an empathic understanding or even an accurate understanding about what might be getting in that person's way. I'm also curious about the fact that I think when we reach for that very quick conclusion, and I appreciate what you just said, which is that we reach for the conclusion in some ways
但他们就是不做。这显然是缺乏意志。是的，绝对是。而且我认为，这种想法之所以能如此迅速地在我们的脑海中闪现，主要原因之一是：当人们不按我们的意愿行事时，无论那是我们的孩子、伴侣、同事还是其他任何人，我们都会感到非常恼火。当我们感到沮丧时，我们人类往往无法很好地调用我们大脑中聪明的部分，
because we are upset, we are frustrated, and the conclusion in some ways helps us deal with our own frustration to say, okay, this person is just not doing what they know is the right thing to do. But of course, once we get into that mindset, now we locate the problem entirely in the other person. And in some ways, what we're doing is we're giving up our own. capacity to potentially help them because we're saying it's no longer anything that we can do that would be helpful. The problem is entirely with this other person. That's right. It's not about
坦白说，我们会非常迅速地诉诸权力和控制，试图让局势重新稳定下来。所以，我认为这就是部分原因。长期以来我们一直相信这一点。围绕这一点有一种传统智慧，即动机，行为完全关乎动机。但随后，当人们不按我们的意愿行事，或者做出我们不希望他们做的事时，这就会让我们感到沮丧。它触发了我们的情绪。这使得我们很难对阻碍那个人的因素产生同理心，甚至无法进行准确的理解。我也很好奇，当我们在得出那个极其迅速的结论时——我赞同你刚才所说的话，即我们在某种程度上得出这个结论
me. It's about them. And that's where a lot of blame happens. We sort of absolve ourselves, take ourselves off the hook, and we just blame the other person. And, you know, the other thing that you're bringing up for me here is when you look at challenging behavior, you know, it doesn't ever happen out of the blue for no reason. People don't explode or implode for no reason. There's something that happens. There's some context. There's some situation. There's some trigger. And often it takes two to tango. It's what you're asking the person to do, how you're asking the person to do it, in what way, et cetera. So, you know, it's not just as simple as the other person's fault. But again, that can make us feel better.
是因为我们心烦意乱、感到沮丧，而且这个结论在某种程度上能帮助我们应对自身的挫败感，告诉自己“好吧，这个人只是不去做他们明知正确的事情”。但当然，一旦我们陷入这种心态，我们就会把问题完全归咎于对方。在某种程度上，我们这样做其实是放弃了自己潜在的帮助他们的能力，因为我们在说，已经没有什么我们能做的事来提供帮助了。问题完全在于对方。没错。这不是关于我的问题，而是关于他们的问题。这就是许多指责发生的地方。我们某种程度上免除了自身的责任，把自己从困境中解脱出来，然后把一切都归咎于对方。而且，你在这里向我提出的另一件事是，当你审视具有挑战性的行为时，你会发现，它从来都不是无缘无故凭空发生的。人们不会无缘无故地情绪爆发或崩溃。一定发生了某些事。存在某种背景。存在某种情境。存在某种触发因素。而且通常一个巴掌拍不响。这取决于你要求对方做什么，你如何要求对方去做，以什么方式去做，等等。所以，这不仅仅是“全是对方的错”那么简单。但再次强调，这样想能让我们感觉好受一些。
I want to talk about some of the skills that might lead to people not being able to change in the way we would like them to change. You sometimes work with children in your practice as a clinical psychologist. You once had a teenage patient who was very hard to get him to open up. Anytime you would try to engage with him in conversation, he would say the same thing over and over again. Tell me about this child, Stuart. So this young man, you know, whenever I would really ask him for information about something, for instance, there was something that happened at school an incident and I wanted his, you know, perspective on it and get his side of the story. And when I would say to him, so can you tell me, you know, what happened? He would say, I don't care, often before
我想谈谈一些可能导致人们无法按照我们的意愿做出改变的技能。你作为一名临床心理学家，有时在诊所里与儿童打交道。你曾有一位十几岁的患者，很难让他敞开心扉。每当你试图与他进行对话时，他总是反反复复地说同一句话。斯图尔特，跟我讲讲这个孩子吧。所以这个年轻人，你知道，每当我真正向他询问某事的信息时，例如，学校里发生了一起事件，我想要他的观点并听听他的说法。当我对他说，你能告诉我发生了什么吗？他就会说，我不在乎，通常在我
I even got a chance to finish my question. And, you know, I would say, well, you know, I'm just sort of curious if you don't mind, because I want to hear your side of the story. So if you can, he'd stop me in the middle. I don't give it. And I said, well, you know, you may not give you, but I sort of do. So I would love to just get your, I don't care. And it just occurred to me that, like, he was sort of heading this off at the past very quickly. And oftentimes I hadn't even finished my question, much less could he possibly have any, have had any time to think about what I was asking him. I actually just said that to him. I said, you know, I just noticed you, you say, I don't care really quickly, like before you even have time to think. So can you do me a favor? Like, can I ask you
甚至还没来得及问完问题时就说了。你知道，我会说，嗯，你知道的，如果你不介意的话，我只是有点好奇，因为我想听听你的说法。所以如果可以的话，他会在中间打断我。我才不管呢。我说，好吧，你知道，你可能不管，但我有点管。所以我很想听听你的，我不在乎。我突然意识到，他似乎很快就把话头给截断了。而且通常情况下，我甚至还没问完问题，更不用说他有什么时间去思考我问他的问题了。我实际上就对他这么说了。我说，你知道，我刚注意到你，你脱口而出一句“我不在乎”的速度非常快，甚至在你来得及思考之前。所以你能帮我个忙吗？我可以问你
the question and I'm going to give you a chance to think. And after you think about it for a while, if you really don't care, don't give it a shit, then tell me that. Okay? And I'll believe you. But give it a chance. And so I asked him the same question. And I said to myself in my head, count to like 45. And so I waited, counted. And somewhere past 30 before 45, he started filling me in a little bit about what happened. And I said to him, so wait a second, you told me you didn't care before, but it sounds like actually, maybe you do. And he said, yeah, I just said that.
这个问题，我要给你一个思考的机会。如果你思考了一段时间后真的不在乎，一点也不在乎，那就告诉我。好吗？我会相信你的。但请给它一个机会。于是我问了他同样的问题。我在心里对自己说，数到45左右。所以我等了，数了。在30之后、45之前的某个时候，他开始向我透露了一点刚才发生的事情。我对他说，等等，你刚才说你不在乎，但听起来实际上你可能是在乎的。他说，是的，我只是那么一说。
I was like, oh, well, I've noticed to say that a lot. Why do you think you do that? And he's like, I don't know. And I decided, let's do the same thing again. But we'll think about it for a sec, because if you really don't know, that's okay, we can try to figure it out together, but think about it. Why do you think when somebody asked you something, you just say, I don't, I don't care. I'm going to give you a minute. And he says, well, nobody's going to wait long enough until I've thought about things until I know what I'm going
我当时想，哦，好吧，我注意到你经常这么说。你觉得你为什么要这么做？他好像说，我不知道。我决定，我们再做一次同样的事情。但我们会花一秒钟想想，因为如果你真的不知道，那也没关系，我们可以试着一起找出答案，但想想看。为什么你觉得当别人问你什么时，你就会说，我不在、我不在乎。我会给你一分钟时间。他说，好吧，没有人会愿意等那么久，直到我想清楚事情，直到我知道我要
to say. So, you know, I might as well just stop it now. So basically what he was doing with, I don't care, I don't give a shit, was basically saying, let's call this off now because it's going to take me a while to process this and come up with my thought and articulate it in spoken language. So you say this is an example of how language and communication skills can influence behavior. Say more about this to it. Well, language and communication skills are just crucial. You know, I always tell people, think about a time when most kids are poorly behaved.
说些什么。所以，你知道，我不如现在就把话头掐断。所以基本上他用“我不在乎”、“我才不管”所做的事情，基本上是在说，我们现在就结束这个话题吧，因为这需要我花上一段时间来处理这件事、组织我的想法并用口头语言表达出来。所以你说这是语言和沟通能力如何影响行为的一个例子。斯图尔特，请多说一点。嗯，语言和沟通能力至关重要。你知道，我总是告诉人们，回想一下大多数孩子表现不佳的时候。
you know, when they have a lot of meltdowns throw a lot of fits. And everybody says, oh, two or three, you know, the terrible twos, right? And think about when kids are two. There's a bunch of things that they're really bad at. And we don't get worried yet because, you know, they're not supposed to be good at those things. But they're horribly inflexible. They can't tolerate frustration and they have terrible problem solving skills. And one of the reasons they have terrible problem solving skills is they're just learning how to communicate with words, which is why you see them communicating all kinds of. of other ways. But as they get better at knowing what's bothering them, putting it into words, engaging in a back and forth to try to solve a problem, their behavior improves as well. Now, the reality is with this young man, he was a lot older than two, but his language skills hadn't really caught up with the average kid his age. You know, it can look lots of different ways. I mean, it can look like a lot of swearing like this kid. A lot of times it looks like kids were adults. who are silent.
你知道的，当他们情绪崩溃、大发脾气的时候。每个人都说，哦，两三岁，所谓的“可怕的两岁”，对吧。想想孩子们两岁的时候。他们有一堆非常不擅长的东西。我们还不必担心，因为，你知道的，他们本来就不应该擅长这些事情。但他们极其缺乏灵活性，无法忍受挫折，而且解决问题的能力糟糕透顶。他们解决问题的能力糟糕透顶的原因之一，就是他们才刚刚学会用词语进行交流，这就是为什么你会看到他们用各种其他方式进行交流。但随着他们越来越擅长弄清楚是什么在困扰他们、用言语表达出来、并通过一来一回的交流来尝试解决问题，他们的行为也会随之改善。然而现实情况是，这个年轻人远不止两岁，但他的语言能力并没有真正赶上他这个年龄的平均水平。你知道，这可以表现为很多不同的形式。我的意思是，它可以表现为像这个孩子一样的大量说脏话。很多时候，它表现为孩子们或是成年人
You might ask them to do something. And they just sort of look at you quietly. And this is where what we talked about earlier comes in because that's when we jump to conclusions. And we have these biases. We think to ourselves, oh, they're refusing to respond. Maybe we think they're being passive aggressive. Maybe they're not being passive aggressive.
保持沉默。你可能会让他们做点什么。他们只是默默地看着你。这就是我们前面讨论过的内容发挥作用的地方，因为正是在这个时候，我们会妄下结论。我们有这些偏见。我们在心里想，哦，他们在拒绝回应。也许我们认为他们是被动攻击。也许他们并不是被动攻击。
Maybe they're just thinking. You know, we have a segment on the show called Your Questions Answered, where we ask listeners to send in questions. And I remember a question that came in recently from this woman. And she said, you know, I've been married, I think, for 50 years. And I feel like I'm in my golden years now with my husband. But I feel like every time I start a conversation, he parries me. He basically blocks me.
也许他们只是在思考。你知道，我们的节目中有一个名为“解答您的提问”的板块，我们邀请听众发来问题。我记得最近一位女士发来了一个问题。她说，你知道，我结婚好像已经50年了。我觉得现在和丈夫一起进入了我的黄金岁月。但我觉得每次我开始对话时，他都在回击我。他基本上是在挡开我。
He doesn't want to engage in the conversation. And every time I bring up, you know, why is it that we're not having a good conversation? He blocks me off at the past. He doesn't talk to me again. And I feel like I'm being stonewalled. You know, I've been stonewalled for years and years and years. And I feel like I don't have a good relationship anymore. And I don't know what to do about it.
他不想参与对话。每次我提起，你知道，为什么我们没有一次好的对话？他就把我的话挡了回去。他不再和我说话。我觉得自己被冷落了。你知道，我被冷落了整整多年。我觉得我不再拥有良好的关系了，我不知道该拿它怎么办。
But in some ways, of course, the specifics might be different. We don't know what's happening with that particular family. But I'm hearing echoes in some ways of the story you just told me with somebody who might be decades younger. Yes. And this is where I say to myself, try not to jump. to conclusions that are blaming, and instead think skill, not will, think maybe this person has a hard time engaging in those conversations. Maybe they're not stonewalling intentionally. And, you know, the other possibility is maybe they have some reasonable concerns about having these
但在某些方面，具体情况当然可能有所不同。我们不知道这个特定家庭发生了什么。但我在某种程度上听到了你刚才讲的那个故事的回声，故事的主人公是一个可能比这年轻几十岁的人。是的。这就是我对自己的告诫：尽量不要妄下带有指责意味的结论，而是要从“技能而非意志”的角度去思考，想想也许这个人很难参与到这些对话中。也许他们并不是故意冷落别人。而且，你知道，另一种可能是，对于进行这些
conversations, but they're not very good at expressing those concerns. So it comes out as stonewalling. Hmm. Another skill that can affect the way we behave and respond in situations is our working memory. Describe what you mean by working memory and how it plays a role here, Stuart. Sure. Working memory, you know, it's not like trying to remember what you had for lunch, you know, a couple of days ago or things like that. Working memory is what neuropsychologists call the cognitive shelf, the shelf we have in our brain, where we can put something up on that shelf. We can still see it. We can grab it. We can grab. habit when we need it. And we are much more reliant on our working memory than we have any idea. You know, I always tell people just having a conversation like we are right now, right?
对话，他们可能有一些合理的担忧，但他们很不擅长表达这些担忧。所以表现出来就成了冷落。嗯。另一个会影响我们在情境中的行为和反应方式的技能是我们的工作记忆。斯图尔特，请描述一下你所说的工作记忆是什么意思，以及它在这里扮演什么角色。当然。工作记忆，你知道，这不像试图记住你几天前午饭吃了什么之类的事情。工作记忆是神经心理学家所说的“认知架子”，即我们大脑中的那个架子，我们可以把某个东西放到那个架子上。我们仍然可以看到它。我们可以抓住它。当我们需要时，我们可以抓住它。我们对工作记忆的依赖程度远超我们的想象。你知道，我总是告诉人们，仅仅进行像我们现在这样的一场对话，对吧？
Like, as I'm talking, what you're hopefully doing is listening and thinking to yourself, hmm, what do I think about what he's saying? So you're holding one piece of information is what is he's saying. Another piece is, what am I thinking about what he's saying? Then hopefully you're also saying to yourself, I wonder how I might respond to what he's saying. And if you're really behaving in the most adaptive way, you're even saying to yourself. And I wonder how he'll respond to what I might say based upon what I think about what he's saying. And by the way, I haven't stopped talking at the same time. So you're holding all this information in your head. And you have to keep all those files open in your head at one time. I often notice this about myself. You know, I'm trying
就像我在说话时，你希望正在做的事情是倾听并在心里想：嗯，我对他说的话有什么看法？所以你在脑海中保持着一条信息，即他在说什么。另一条信息是：我对他说的话有什么看法？然后，希望你也在对自己说：我不知道我该如何回应他说的话。如果你确实在以最具适应性的方式行事，你甚至会对自己说：我想根据我对他说的话的看法，他会如何回应我可能要说的话。顺便说一句，与此同时我并没有停止说话。所以你把所有这些信息都装在脑子里。你必须同时在脑子里保持所有这些文件处于打开状态。我经常在自己身上注意到这一点。你知道，我试图
to get something and I say, okay, I need to get this piece of information. And this piece of information is in this other file over here. So I go to that file. But I realize there's something there that's missing or that I need something else in order to get that information. And now I'm suddenly three steps down the rabbit hole. And I have to remember how to climb my way back to the problem I had in the first place. And all of that is working memory. It is. And what you're also pointing out here is that working memory is incredibly closely related to other skills that have to do with attention and organization. And this is why when we study working memory, we often sort of lump it together with attentional skills because those they sort of go together and they all amount to our ability
得到某样东西，我说，好吧，我需要获取这条信息。而这条信息在这里的另一个文件夹里。所以我去找那个文件夹。但我意识到那里有什么东西漏掉了，或者我需要其他东西才能获取那条信息。而现在我突然陷入了三步之遥的困境。我必须记住如何顺藤摸瓜爬回我一开始遇到的问题。所有这些都是工作记忆。确实如此。而你在这里也指出，工作记忆与注意力、组织能力等其他技能密切相关。这就是为什么当我们研究工作记忆时，我们经常把它和注意力技能归为一类，因为它们有点像是一伙的，它们都关乎我们的能力
to stay organized as well, which is, again, a skill. And the fancy term for some of these skills is what we call executive functioning skills, the sort of CEO of your brain, if you will. So when we want someone to do something complex, you know, we want a kid to work hard in a class and study, for example, there might be a whole set of study skills that are involved before you can actually get to what the class is even about. You got it. Absolutely. And, you know, we take these things for granted. A kid I worked with, his room was always a mess like many other kids and his parents were furious and would tell him to go clean his room and you'd go into his room and there'd be like heaps of laundry on the floor the place was like look like a bomb hit it and he
同样保持条理性，这其实也是一种技能。这些技能的一个专业术语就是我们所说的执行功能技能，也就是你大脑的CEO，如果你愿意这么称呼的话。所以，当我们希望某人做一件复杂的事情时，比如我们希望一个孩子在课堂上努力学习并做功课，在真正接触到课堂内容之前，可能会涉及一整套学习技能。完全正确。绝对是的。而且，你知道，我们把这些理所当然地看作是小事。我曾共事过的一个孩子，他的房间总是乱七八糟，就像许多其他孩子一样，他的父母非常愤怒，告诉他去把房间打扫干净。你走进他的房间，地板上会堆满换洗的衣服，那地方看起来就像被炸弹炸过一样，而他
would go up to the above his desk where he had some shelves and he would start like dusting his action figures on the top corner of the shelf where you know the biggest bang for your buck would be take all the laundry and put it in the laundry basket take you three seconds it'll whole place will look a lot better. But this kid, he had a hard time thinking big picture and organizing like that. And that's a skill. My mom used to tell me the story when she was, I think, in either high school or college, and she was having real trouble in various classes. And it took actually several months for people to realize that what was happening was she was developing myopia and she simply couldn't see what was happening on the board.
会走到书桌上方有书架的地方，开始像擦拭书架最高角落里那些动作玩偶上的灰尘一样，你知道，在那儿能发挥最大效用，而把所有的衣服捡起来放进洗衣篮里只需要花你三秒钟，整个地方看起来就会好得多。但这个孩子，他很难从宏观角度思考并进行那样的整理。而这正是一种技能。我妈妈以前给我讲过一个故事，当时她好像在上高中或大学，她在各种课程上都遇到了真正的麻烦。事实上，人们花了几个月的时间才意识到发生的事情是她患上了近视，而她根本看不清黑板上写的内容。
I mean, that's a very practical kind of skill that we need, the ability to see clearly. But in some ways, what you're talking about is the psychological analogy for that, which is that when we can't do something, it could be because we're simply not able to do it. Yes. And to use that analogy, if you tell somebody who can't see something, like I, you know, for instance, when I wear my contact lenses, I can't read very small print. You could offer me the biggest incentive in the world or tell me that I've got the biggest consequence coming. if I don't read it, it will not help. And in fact, it'll decrease my performance because it'll be incredibly frustrating to be more motivated but still unable to do it. Not to mention that when you try
我的意思是，这是我们需要的一种非常现实的技能，即清晰视物的能力。但在某种程度上，你所谈论的是它的心理学类比，也就是说，当我们做不到某事时，可能是因为我们根本做不到。是的。借用这个类比，如果你告诉一个看不清东西的人——比如我，戴隐形眼镜时，我就看不太清很小的字——你可以给我世界上最丰厚的奖励，或者告诉我如果不去读它会有多么严重的后果，这都无济于事。事实上，这会降低我的表现，因为在更有动力却仍然做不到的情况下，会让人感到无比沮丧。更不用说当你试图
to motivate people to do things that they struggle to do, you know, you also send them the not so subtle message that you don't think they're trying hard enough or else why would you be trying to motivate them. And, you know, with kids, I can tell you, that has caused. so much damage to so many kids' self-esteem? I mean, in some ways, I think it's easier to see the problem when the problem is a physical problem of some kind, right? So, in other words, if someone can't see the board, you can say, I can take them to the optometrist,
激励人们去做那些他们觉得吃力的事时，你知道，你也在向他们传递一个不太含蓄的信息：你认为他们还不够努力，否则你为什么要试图激励他们呢？而且，你知道，对于孩子们，我可以告诉你，这给许多孩子的自尊心造成了如此之大的损害！我的意思是，在某种程度上，我认为当问题是某种身体问题时，更容易看出问题所在，对吧？换句话说，如果有人看不见黑板，你可以说，我可以带他们去验光，
I can give them a test, I can tell that they can't see the board, and here's the fix, and so forth. I think partly because some of these skills that you're talking about are subtler, and they're psychological, they're not immediately visible, and so all we see is the outcome, which is the kid doesn't seem to be cleaning his room. Absolutely. Absolutely. And yet, the interesting thing is, if we line up 100 people who struggle with their behavior and 100 people who don't, and I brought them back to our Department of Psychiatry here at Mass General Hospital where I work and gave them all neuropsychological evaluations, tests, just like an optometrist might test your eyes. Guess what you'll see. You'll see the people who struggle with their behavior have huge differences in skills.
我可以给他们做测试，我能看出他们看不见黑板，这里有解决办法，诸如此类。我想部分原因是因为你谈到的一些技能更微妙，它们是心理层面的，不是立刻就能肉眼可见的，所以我们看到的只有结果，也就是这个孩子似乎没有在打扫房间。绝对是的。绝对是的。然而有趣的是，如果我们排成一队，让100个在行为上有困难的人和100个没有困难的人站在一起，然后我把他们带回我工作的麻省总医院精神病学系，给他们所有人做神经心理学评估和测试，就像验光师可能测试你的眼睛一样。你猜你会看到什么。你会看到那些在行为上有困难的人在技能上存在巨大差异。
And we're starting to cover those now. One of the other areas you've looked at, Stuart, is emotion regulation. Talk about this skill. So emotion regulation that refers to our skills at controlling or managing our emotions. And, you know, one of the things we know about us humans is that there's sort of like a negative correlation between feeling and thinking. that the more we're flooded by feeling, the less clearly we are able to think. And feeling is good. Feeling tells us when there's problems we need to solve, but it doesn't tend to solve
我们现在开始讨论这些了。斯图尔特，你研究的另一个领域是情绪调节。谈谈这项技能。情绪调节指的是我们控制或管理情绪的技能。你知道，关于我们人类，我们所知道的事情之一就是，感觉和思考之间存在着某种负相关关系，即我们被情感淹没得越厉害，我们清晰思考的能力就越弱。而感觉是件好事。感觉告诉我们何时出现了需要解决的问题，但它往往无法解决
problems. We need our thinking skills. And so emotion regulation skills are our skills at being able to sort of tamp down or manage or control our emotional response so that we can think straight. And that may be emotional response to frustration, to anger, to disappointment. It could be our emotional response to excitement, to joy, nervousness, worry, et cetera. And those are skills. Talk about the category of skills that fall into the domain of the social.
问题。我们需要我们的思考技能。因此，情绪调节技能就是我们能够平息、管理或控制情感反应的技能，这样我们才能清醒地思考。这可能是对挫折、愤怒、失望的情感反应。这也可能是我们对兴奋、快乐、紧张、担忧等的情感反应。这些都是技能。谈谈属于社交领域的那类技能。
Our relationships with others are ability to deal well with others, to negotiate well with others. Talk about this as being a skill. Again, I think many of us assume some people just have it, some people don't have it, some people know how to get along with others, some people don't. Talk about this as a skills to it. yes sure um and i refer to these as social thinking skills really and these are everything from like things that seem really basic for some people like how do you start a conversation with somebody or you see a group of people that you want to join doing something how do you join that group
我们与他人的关系、与他人良好相处的能力、与他人良好协商的能力。请把这当作一项技能来谈谈。同样，我想我们中的许多人认为有些人天生就有，有些人则没有，有些人知道如何与他人相处，有些人则不知道。斯图尔特，请把这作为一种技能来谈谈。是的，当然，嗯，我真的把这些称为社交思维技能。这些包括了从对某些人来说似乎非常基础的事情，比如你如何与某人开始对话，或者你看到一群人正在做你想加入的事情，你如何加入那个群组
without sort of upsetting the apple cart um to more complicated skills like how do you know how you're coming across or how your behavior is impacting somebody else. I call it your feedback loop because, you know, we're all hugely dependent on it. We all do things and we scan and we see, how did that go across? And we sort of change our behavior accordingly. But I've worked with lots of people who have a broken feedback loop. They sort of don't get the feedback from the environment so they might keep doing something that's annoying to other people or off-putting. And, you know, I would say some of the most complicated social thinking skills are things like perspective taking, putting yourself in somebody else's shoes, and empathy. Empathy may be the most
而又不会打破这种和谐，到更复杂的技能，比如你如何知道自己给别人留下了什么印象，或者你的行为如何影响了别人。我称之为你的反馈循环，因为，你知道的，我们所有人都极大地依赖于它。我们所有人做事情时都会进行扫描并观察：效果怎么样？然后我们相应地改变我们的行为。但我曾与许多人合作过，他们的反馈循环坏掉了。他们某种程度上接收不到来自环境的反馈，所以他们可能会一直做一些让别人觉得讨厌或反感的事情。而且，你知道，我想说，一些最复杂的社交思维技能是诸如视角转换、设身处地为他人着想以及同理心之类的东西。同理心可能是最
complicated social thinking skill. So one of your central ideas is that people do well if they can do well, not if they want to do well. Talk about this distinction. Yeah, sure. This is sort of the core foundational idea behind our work. The notion, the philosophy that we taught, which we still teach today, is kids do well if they can, applied to adults, adults do well if they can. In other words, people do well if they can suggest is, you know what, don't we all want to do well? Like, show me the person who prefers doing poorly in the world. I've never met that person, who prefers that things are going poorly at work, who prefers their partners upset with them, who prefers that their parents are constantly
复杂的社交思维技能。所以你的核心观点之一是：人们如果能做好，就会做好，而不是如果想做好就能做好。谈谈这种区别。是的，当然。这是我们工作背后的核心基础理念。我们过去教导的、今天仍在教导的观点/哲学是：“孩子们如果能做到，就会做好”；将其应用到成年人身上，就是“成年人如果能做到，就会做好”。换句话说，“人们如果能做好，就会做好”暗示了，你知道吗，难道我们不都想做好吗？比如，给我看看那个更愿意在这个世界上表现糟糕的人。我从来没有遇到过这样的人，他更愿意工作进展不顺利，更愿意伴侣生他的气，更愿意父母总是
or teachers are upset. No, people do well if they can. If they can, they will. Now, that's a stark contrast to the notion of people do well if they want to. Because what people do well if they want to suggests is if they're not doing well, it must be because they don't want to. What we need to do is make them want to. And, you know, if only were as simple as that. My thought is people do well if they can. If they could, they would. And if they're not, let's use what we've learned in the last 50 years in terms of what might be getting in their way. One of the things that I'm taking away from our conversation, Stuart, is that it's possible that there might be situations where, in fact, people, you know, can do something, but they don't want to do something.
或者老师对他们感到生气。不，人们如果能做好，就会做好。如果他们能，他们就会去做。现在，这与“人们如果想做好，就会做好”的概念形成了鲜明对比。因为“人们如果想做好，就会做好”所暗示的是，如果他们没有做好，那一定是因为他们不想做好。我们需要做的是让他们想要做好。而且，你知道，要是事情有那么简单就好了。我的想法是，人们如果能做好，就会做好。如果他们能，他们就会去做。如果他们没有，让我们利用过去50年在了解可能阻碍他们的因素方面所学到的知识。斯图尔特，我从我们的对话中带走的一个观点是，在某些情况下，事实上人们（你知道的）能够做某事，但他们就是不想做。
It's possible that in some ways it's a problem of will. but I think the problem that arises when we assume that it's a problem of will as opposed to a problem of skill is it deprives us of our ability to do anything to help them. As you're talking and as you're describing these various skills, I'm thinking about various issues and various relationships that I have and people whom I know and things that I would like to see changed. And suddenly I'm thinking about them differently. I'm thinking about them as saying, you know,
It's possible that in some ways it's a problem of will. but I think the problem that arises when we assume that it's a problem of will as opposed to a problem of skill is it deprives us of our ability to do anything to help them. As you're talking and as you're describing these various skills, I'm thinking about various issues and various relationships that I have and people whom I know and things that I would like to see changed. And suddenly I'm thinking about them differently. I'm thinking about them as saying, you know,|||在某些方面，这可能是一个意志问题。但我觉得，当我们把它假设为一个意志问题，而不是技能问题时，所产生的问题在于，它剥夺了我们去帮助他们的能力。听着你的讲述，听着你描述这些不同的技能，我想到了我身边的各种问题、各种关系、我认识的人，以及我希望看到改变的事情。突然之间，我对它们的看法变了。我开始这样想，你知道的，
what if I could help this person develop this skill as opposed to what if I could just get into this person's sense? thick skull what they need to be doing. It's a very different mindset. It's a huge shift in thinking. And what it does, as you're articulating beautifully, is it positions you in a much more empathic understanding place. And empathy is the bedrock of being able to help anyone. So, you know, instead of blaming and wanting to control, it puts you in a solid place of non-judgmental, empathy, acceptance, and interest in what's going on for this person. When we come back, how to inspire change by focusing on skill building instead of battles
what if I could help this person develop this skill as opposed to what if I could just get into this person's sense? thick skull what they need to be doing. It's a very different mindset. It's a huge shift in thinking. And what it does, as you're articulating beautifully, is it positions you in a much more empathic understanding place. And empathy is the bedrock of being able to help anyone. So, you know, instead of blaming and wanting to control, it puts you in a solid place of non-judgmental, empathy, acceptance, and interest in what's going on for this person. When we come back, how to inspire change by focusing on skill building instead of battles|||如果我能帮助这个人培养这项技能会怎么样，而不是我怎么才能把他们需要做的事情硬塞进他们那顽固的脑袋里？这是一种截然不同的心态。这是一个巨大的思维转变。正如你精彩阐述的那样，它带来的效果是，让你站在一个更有同理心、更能理解的立场上。而同理心是能够帮助任何人的基石。所以，你知道的，它取代了指责和控制欲，让你稳稳地站在不加评判、充满同理心、接纳以及对这个人的现状感兴趣的立场上。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何通过专注于技能培养而不是意志较量来激发改变，
of will, not just in children, but in grown-ups too. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. When we encounter bad behavior, our instinct is often to discipline the behavior. We try to impose our will using rewards and consequences to force the behavior change. Sometimes this works. Sometimes it doesn't. Psychologist Stuart Ablon is the author of the book, Changeable, how collaborative problem-solving changes lives at home.
of will, not just in children, but in grown-ups too. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. When we encounter bad behavior, our instinct is often to discipline the behavior. We try to impose our will using rewards and consequences to force the behavior change. Sometimes this works. Sometimes it doesn't. Psychologist Stuart Ablon is the author of the book, Changeable, how collaborative problem-solving changes lives at home.|||对象不仅是孩子，也包括成年人。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当我们遇到不良行为时，我们的本能往往是惩戒这种行为。我们试图通过奖惩来强加我们的意志，以迫使行为发生改变。有时这管用，有时则不然。心理学家斯图尔特·阿布隆是《可改变的：协作解决问题如何改变家庭生活》一书的作者。
Stuart, you say the standard approach we use to change people's behavior is something you call Plan A. Define Plan A for me. Sure. Plan A is basically when you try to impose your will to make somebody do what you want them to do. So, you know, whether it's harshly, gently, anything in between, if you're really just trying to make that person do what you want them to do, we call that Plan A. So Planoe sounds pretty good on paper. I mean, if you can actually get someone to change their behavior and this behavior is irritating, what's the downside?
Stuart, you say the standard approach we use to change people's behavior is something you call Plan A. Define Plan A for me. Sure. Plan A is basically when you try to impose your will to make somebody do what you want them to do. So, you know, whether it's harshly, gently, anything in between, if you're really just trying to make that person do what you want them to do, we call that Plan A. So Planoe sounds pretty good on paper. I mean, if you can actually get someone to change their behavior and this behavior is irritating, what's the downside?|||斯图尔特，你说我们用来改变他人行为的标准方法是你所说的“A计划”。请为我定义一下“A计划”。当然。A计划基本上就是当你试图强加自己的意志，让某人做你希望他们做的事情时采用的方法。所以，你知道的，无论是严厉地、温和地，还是介于两者之间的任何方式，如果你真的只是在试图让那个人做你希望他们做的事，我们就称之为A计划。所以，A计划在理论上听起来相当不错。我的意思是，如果你真的能让某人改变他们的行为，而这种行为又很烦人，那有什么缺点呢？
It's fascinating because whether you're talking to a preschool teacher, a correctional facility guard, a police officer, someone in the corporate world, you name it, People always say the same thing, which is that trying to impose your will is an attempt to get your expectations met, but often isn't successful, often escalates poor behavior, doesn't actually build any rapport or relationship, and the problem tends to live on. Also, if this is a person struggling with any skills, those skills don't get practiced or built when you try to impose your will as well. So before we get to plan B, I want to shake things up a little bit and have you tell me what plan C is in this rubric that you've created, Stuart.
It's fascinating because whether you're talking to a preschool teacher, a correctional facility guard, a police officer, someone in the corporate world, you name it, People always say the same thing, which is that trying to impose your will is an attempt to get your expectations met, but often isn't successful, often escalates poor behavior, doesn't actually build any rapport or relationship, and the problem tends to live on. Also, if this is a person struggling with any skills, those skills don't get practiced or built when you try to impose your will as well. So before we get to plan B, I want to shake things up a little bit and have you tell me what plan C is in this rubric that you've created, Stuart.|||这很迷人，因为无论你跟幼儿园老师、惩教所警卫、警察、职场人士还是其他什么人谈论，大家总是说同样的话：那就是，试图强加你的意志虽然是为了满足你的期望，但往往不会成功，还经常会使不良行为升级，实际上无法建立任何融洽的关系，问题也往往依然存在。此外，如果这个人正挣扎于某些技能的缺乏，当你试图强加意志时，这些技能也得不到练习或建立。所以在我们讨论B计划之前，我想稍微转换一下话题，请你告诉我，在你创建的这个分类体系中，C计划是什么，斯图尔特。
Sure. Plan C is when you decide to drop your expectation or to solve the problem the way the other person wants it solved, which very important clarification here is not, quote, giving in, because that's what people fear it is. It's not giving in. Giving in is when you try plan A, you try to impose your will and you can't pull it off and you bail and you sort of just give up. That's not plan C. That's failed plan A leading to bailing. Plan C is when you are planful. It's a strategic decision. You are deciding, I'm not going
Sure. Plan C is when you decide to drop your expectation or to solve the problem the way the other person wants it solved, which very important clarification here is not, quote, giving in, because that's what people fear it is. It's not giving in. Giving in is when you try plan A, you try to impose your will and you can't pull it off and you bail and you sort of just give up. That's not plan C. That's failed plan A leading to bailing. Plan C is when you are planful. It's a strategic decision. You are deciding, I'm not going|||当然。C计划是指你决定放弃你的期望，或者按照对方希望的方式去解决问题。这里需要作出一个非常重要的澄清：这并不是所谓的“妥协”，因为这正是人们所害怕的。这不是妥协。妥协是指当你尝试了A计划、试图强加你的意志却无法成功时，你选择抽身并有点像是直接放弃了。那不是C计划。那是失败的A计划导致的退缩。C计划是指你是有计划性的。这是一个战略性的决定。你决定：我不会
to pursue this, at least right now. Maybe not, this is not forever, just for now I'm not going to, or I'm going to solve it for now the way the other person wants it solved. And the reason you might do that is to keep the calm. Plan C can decrease challenging behavior. If you drop an expectation, that leads to challenging behavior, you're going to get less challenging behavior. Now, you haven't solved the problem. You haven't gotten your expectations met, but you've avoided a challenge, for instance. And there's a place for that. Is there a better way than either plan A or plan C? Absolutely. And here's the thing. People so often get stuck, whether it's in a home, a school, a workplace, in what I call the AC split. In a two-parent household, for instance, the AC split is one
to pursue this, at least right now. Maybe not, this is not forever, just for now I'm not going to, or I'm going to solve it for now the way the other person wants it solved. And the reason you might do that is to keep the calm. Plan C can decrease challenging behavior. If you drop an expectation, that leads to challenging behavior, you're going to get less challenging behavior. Now, you haven't solved the problem. You haven't gotten your expectations met, but you've avoided a challenge, for instance. And there's a place for that. Is there a better way than either plan A or plan C? Absolutely. And here's the thing. People so often get stuck, whether it's in a home, a school, a workplace, in what I call the AC split. In a two-parent household, for instance, the AC split is one|||去追求这个了，至少现在不会。也许吧，这并不是永远，只是暂时不去做，或者暂时按照对方希望的方式去解决它。你之所以这么做，原因可能是为了保持平静。C计划可以减少挑衅行为。如果你放弃了一个会导致挑衅行为的期望，你就会遇到较少的挑衅行为。现在，你并没有解决问题。你没有让自己的期望得到满足，但例如，你避免了一场冲突。这种方法有其用武之地。有没有比A计划或C计划更好的方法？当然有。事情是这样的：人们经常陷入我所说的“AC分裂”之中，无论是在家里、学校还是职场。例如，在一个双亲家庭中，AC分裂表现为其中一个
parent's the plan A parent, one parent's the plan C parent. But this happens. happens in workplaces as well. And what I like to say is you don't get plan B by the average of A and C. And there is another option. And that's plan B. Plan B is collaborative problem solving. It is working together to solve a problem in mutually satisfactory ways. And it has a clear set of guideposts to it that have been refined over years of practice and study at this point. what are these guideposts to it basically there's um three steps or i prefer to call them ingredients okay uh and just to be clear at the outset you can't use plan b on someone this is a process that you do with someone but it has clear guideposts and feel free to share those guideposts
parent's the plan A parent, one parent's the plan C parent. But this happens. happens in workplaces as well. And what I like to say is you don't get plan B by the average of A and C. And there is another option. And that's plan B. Plan B is collaborative problem solving. It is working together to solve a problem in mutually satisfactory ways. And it has a clear set of guideposts to it that have been refined over years of practice and study at this point. what are these guideposts to it basically there's um three steps or i prefer to call them ingredients okay uh and just to be clear at the outset you can't use plan b on someone this is a process that you do with someone but it has clear guideposts and feel free to share those guideposts|||家长是A计划型的家长，另一个家长是C计划型的家长。但这也会发生在职场中。我常说的一句话是，你无法通过折中A和C来得到B计划。还有另一种选择，那就是B计划。B计划是协作解决问题。它是通过对双方都满意的途径共同努力来解决问题。它有一套清晰的指导方针，这些方针经过了多年的实践和研究的提炼。这些指导方针是什么呢？基本上有嗯三个步骤，或者我更喜欢称之为要素，好的。呃，一开始要说明白的是，你不能对某人使用B计划，这是一个与某人共同经历的过程，但它有清晰的指导方针，你可以随意将这些指导方针
with the person that you are doing this with is nothing hidden about this this is transparent so the guideposts these three ingredients are first ingredient the empathy ingredient And that is where you try to understand the other person's concern, perspective, point of view, or what's hard about a situation. And only once you've done that, that first ingredient, the empathy ingredient, do you move to the second ingredient, where you get to share your concern, your perspective, your point of view, or what you're worried about? And only once you have two sets of concerns on the table, do you go to the third ingredient where you invite that person to work together, to collaborate, to collaborate, with you to solve the problem. You must have both parties' concerns on the table. Just to drill down a little bit deeper into each of these three steps, I think when we genuinely ask someone what their problem is, and you did that with a kid who was basically
with the person that you are doing this with is nothing hidden about this this is transparent so the guideposts these three ingredients are first ingredient the empathy ingredient And that is where you try to understand the other person's concern, perspective, point of view, or what's hard about a situation. And only once you've that, that first ingredient, the empathy ingredient, do you move to the second ingredient, where you get to share your concern, your perspective, your point of view, or what you're worried about? And only once you have two sets of concerns on the table, do you go to the third ingredient where you invite that person to work together, to collaborate, to collaborate, with you to solve the problem. You must have both parties' concerns on the table. Just to drill down a little bit deeper into each of these three steps, I think when we genuinely ask someone what their problem is, and you did that with a kid who was basically|||分享给你正在一起处理这件事的人。这里没有任何隐藏的东西，这是完全透明的。因此，这些指导方针，这三个要素是：第一要素——同理心要素。这就是你试着去理解对方的担忧、视角、观点，或者某个处境难在哪里的时候。只有当你完成了第一要素——同理心要素之后，你才能进入第二要素，即分享你的担忧、你的视角、你的观点，或者你所担心的事情。只有当两套担忧都摆在台面上时，你才能进入第三要素，即邀请那个人与你一起努力、协作、合作来解决问题。你必须把双方的担忧都摆在台面上。为了更深入地探讨这三个步骤中的每一步，我认为，当我们真诚地询问某人的问题是什么时——你曾对一个基本上是
shutting you off at the past and saying, I don't know, I don't care. When you genuinely ask that question, I think there's an element of courage that's required when you're this? Because I think very often, I'm not sure we actually want to know what's preventing someone from doing the thing that we want them to do. We don't want to know that there's a genuine problem, a genuine roadblock. And what you're saying is that that empathy is actually really an important first step. Absolutely. And there's a stance, okay? You know, when people hear the word empathy, by the way, they often misunderstand it. They think empathy means to sort of show you care and that you can empathize by saying, you know, I really want to work this out
shutting you off at the past and saying, I don't know, I don't care. When you genuinely ask that question, I think there's an element of courage that's required when you're this? Because I think very often, I'm not sure we actually want to know what's preventing someone from doing the thing that we want them to do. We don't want to know that there's a genuine problem, a genuine roadblock. And what you're saying is that that empathy is actually really an important first step. Absolutely. And there's a stance, okay? You know, when people hear the word empathy, by the way, they often misunderstand it. They think empathy means to sort of show you care and that you can empathize by saying, you know, I really want to work this out|||把话头掐断、说“我不知道、我不在乎”的孩子这样做过——当你真诚地提出那个问题时，我觉得这样做需要一定的勇气。因为我认为很多时候，我不确定我们是否真的想知道是什么阻碍了别人去做我们希望他们做的事。我们不想知道存在一个真正的问题、一个真正的路障。而你所说的是，同理心其实真的是一个非常重要的第一步。绝对是的。而且这里有一种态度，好吗？顺便说一句，当人们听到“同理心”这个词时，经常会误解它。他们认为同理心意味着表现出你的关心，并且可以通过说“你知道的，我真的很想解决这个问题”来表示感同身受。
with you. Like, that's empathy. That's not empathy. If anything, it's like drive by empathy, but real empathy, the definition of the word empathy, is to understand. And you have to work hard to try to understand somebody else's point of view and perspective. And you're right, that sometimes we may not like what we're going to hear. And there's a really important lesson in here, which is I'm constantly trying to remind myself and others that empathy doesn't mean to agree or to disagree. Empathy is not agreeing or disagree. It is simply understanding. And actually, believe it or not, you can completely and totally disagree with somebody's perspective and point of view, and you can still empathize by understanding. And frankly, I think this has
with you. Like, that's empathy. That's not empathy. If anything, it's like drive by empathy, but real empathy, the definition of the word empathy, is to understand. And you have to work hard to try to understand somebody else's point of view and perspective. And you're right, that sometimes we may not like what we're going to hear. And there's a really important lesson in here, which is I'm constantly trying to remind myself and others that empathy doesn't mean to agree or to disagree. Empathy is not agreeing or disagree. It is simply understanding. And actually, believe it or not, you can completely and totally disagree with somebody's perspective and point of view, and you can still empathize by understanding. And frankly, I think this has|||像这样，这就是同理心。那不是同理心。硬要说的话，这就像是“路过式同理心”，而真正的同理心，同理心这个词的定义，是理解。你必须努力去理解别人的观点和视角。你说得对，有时我们可能不喜欢我们将要听到的内容。这里面有一个非常重要的教训，那就是我一直在提醒自己和他人：同理心并不意味着同意或不同意。同理心不是同意或不同意，它仅仅是理解。事实上，信不信由你，你可以完全、彻底地不同意某个人的观点和视角，但你依然可以通过理解来产生同理心。坦白说，我认为这已经
become something that we've gotten worse and worse at, which is when you don't agree with somebody, can you still understand and listen to them? Let's just drill down a moment into that first point that you're making Stuart, the idea of being empathetic and curious. You say that even here, there are actually multiple elements to this prong. What do they involve? Well, so, you know, as I mentioned, empathy is hard. It's not what people think it is. Empathy is understanding.
become something that we've gotten worse and worse at, which is when you don't agree with somebody, can you still understand and listen to them? Let's just drill down a moment into that first point that you're making Stuart, the idea of being empathetic and curious. You say that even here, there are actually multiple elements to this prong. What do they involve? Well, so, you know, as I mentioned, empathy is hard. It's not what people think it is. Empathy is understanding.|||变成了我们越来越不擅长的一件事，那就是：当你不同意某人的观点时，你还能不能理解并倾听他们？斯图尔特，让我们深入探讨一下你刚才提出的第一点，即保持同理心和好奇心的理念。你说即使在这里，这个核心要点实际上也包含多个要素。它们涉及哪些内容？嗯，所以，你知道的，正如我所提到的，同理心很难。它不像人们想象的那样。同理心就是理解。
And it's really hard for people to do. And I've had the opportunity to watch so many people in so many different places to try. try to do collaborative problem solving, and the first ingredient is the hardest. And so what I did is I actually started to take all these recordings, audio, video recordings of all these attempts that people made at doing collaborative problem solving and just studying the first ingredient. And of course, my own attempts as well. And what I found is fascinating, that when it goes well, when we're doing a good job empathizing, we're doing four things and four things only. These four things are, like any good detective would, asking a lot of questions, clarifying questions.
And it's really hard for people to do. And I've had the opportunity to watch so many people in so many different places to try. try to do collaborative problem solving, and the first ingredient is the hardest. And so what I did is I actually started to take all these recordings, audio, video recordings of all these attempts that people made at doing collaborative problem solving and just studying the first ingredient. And of course, my own attempts as well. And what I found is fascinating, that when it goes well, when we're doing a good job empathizing, we're doing four things and four things only. These four things are, like any good detective would, asking a lot of questions, clarifying questions.|||这对人们来说真的很难做到。我有机会在许多不同的地方观察了许多人，看他们尝试进行协作式问题解决，而第一要素是最难的。所以我做的事情是，我开始收集所有这些录音、视频录音记录人们在尝试协作解决问题时所做的各种尝试，专门研究第一要素。当然，还有我自己的尝试。我发现的结果非常迷人：当进展顺利时，当我们把同理心工作做好时，我们只做了四件事，而且仅仅四件事。这四件事就像任何优秀的侦探会做的那样：提出大量问题，即澄清问题。
If you're not getting information, educated guessing. That's the second thing. If you get any information, either in response to your question or in response to an educated guess, you reflect back in your own words what you've heard from the person. We call that reflective listening, okay? And that shows you're listening, okay? And the fourth thing is reassurance. Okay. And what reassurance is is your way of saying this is not some tricky form of plan A. So it's you saying things like, don't worry, you're not in trouble, or I'm just trying to understand, or one of my personal favorites, I know there must be an important reason that fill in the blank, okay? Because what I always remind myself is I may not love the person's behavior, but I'm sure they've got a good reason, a good concern, a good perspective. That's what you're on the hunt for.
If you're not getting information, educated guessing. That's the second thing. If you get any information, either in response to your question or in response to an educated guess, you reflect back in your own words what you've heard from the person. We call that reflective listening, okay? And that shows you're listening, okay? And the fourth thing is reassurance. Okay. And what reassurance is is your way of saying this is not some tricky form of plan A. So it's you saying things like, don't worry, you're not in trouble, or I'm just trying to understand, or one of my personal favorites, I know there must be an important reason that fill in the blank, okay? Because what I always remind myself is I may not love the person's behavior, but I'm sure they've got a good reason, a good concern, a good perspective. That's what you're on the hunt for.|||如果你没有获得信息，就进行有根据的猜测。这是第二件事。如果你获得了任何信息，无论是对你提问的回应，还是对有根据的猜测的回应，你都要用你自己的话把从对方那里听到的话复述出来。我们称之为“反思性倾听”，好吧？这表明你在倾听，好吗？第四件事是安慰。好的。安慰的意思是，你用这种方式告诉对方，这不是A计划的某种诡计。所以你会说这样的话：“别担心，你没有惹麻烦”，或者“我只是想理解”，或者我个人最喜欢的话之一：“我知道一定有一个重要的原因，那就是——（填空）”，好吗？因为我总是提醒自己：我可能不喜欢这个人的行为，但我确信他们一定有一个好理由、一个好担忧、一个好视角。这正是你所寻找的。
And the last thing I would say about this is your stance should be one of curiosity. It is way too easy to enter a conversation with preconceived notions and judgments. Suspend those, ask questions, take guesses, reflect what you've heard, reassure if necessary, and you'll learn a lot. So the second step that you suggested a second ago is that once you've heard, reassure if necessary, and you'll learn a lot. you've done the necessary empathizing, you've tried to understand where the other person is coming from, you put your own perspective on the table. But I can see how this might backfires to it. I listen to you very carefully. I'm patient. I'm genuinely curious. I try and understand where you're coming from. And once I've understood it, I say, all right,
And the last thing I would say about this is your stance should be one of curiosity. It is way too easy to enter a conversation with preconceived notions and judgments. Suspend those, ask questions, take guesses, reflect what you've heard, reassure if necessary, and you'll learn a lot. So the second step that you suggested a second ago is that once you've heard, reassure if necessary, and you'll learn a lot. you've done the necessary empathizing, you've tried to understand where the other person is coming from, you put your own perspective on the table. But I can see how this might backfires to it. I listen to you very carefully. I'm patient. I'm genuinely curious. I try and understand where you're coming from. And once I've understood it, I say, all right,|||关于这一点，我要说的最后一点是，你的立场应该充满好奇心。带着先入为主的观念和判断进入对话实在是太容易了。悬置这些观念和判断，提出问题，进行猜测，反思你所听到的话，必要时给予安慰，你会学到很多东西。所以你刚才提到的第二步是，一旦你完成了必要的同理心建设，尝试过去理解对方的出发点，你就可以把自己的视角摆上台面。但我能看出这可能会带来反效果，斯图尔特。我非常仔细地倾听你。我有耐心。我真的很好奇。我努力去理解你的出发点。一旦我理解了，我说：“好吧，
that's all well and good, but here's what I think. Could that be a problem? It could be a problem. And the first thing I'm going to suggest is a little tweak in wording, not that there's magic words out there, but the word but almost sort of implies, okay, I heard you, but guess what? My perspective is different or more important than yours. I always encourage people to say, you know, once you've heard the other person out, first of all, summarize what you've heard from them so that you really are showing you've heard it, and then use the word and instead, and just say, and, you know, here's my point of view or here's my concern or my perspective. Now, what you're saying is the person might get upset with that or sort of, you know,
that's all well and good, but here's what I think. Could that be a problem? It could be a problem. And the first thing I'm going to suggest is a little tweak in wording, not that there's magic words out there, but the word but almost sort of implies, okay, I heard you, but guess what? My perspective is different or more important than yours. I always encourage people to say, you know, once you've heard the other person out, first of all, summarize what you've heard from them so that you really are showing you've heard it, and then use the word and instead, and just say, and, you know, here's my point of view or here's my concern or my perspective. Now, what you're saying is the person might get upset with that or sort of, you know,|||这都很好，但我是这么想的。”这会不会成问题？这可能会成问题。我首先要建议的是稍微调整一下用词——倒不是说世上有什么魔咒般的词汇，但“但是”这个词几乎在某种程度上暗示了：好吧，我听到你说的了，但你猜怎么着？我的视角跟你的不同，或者比你的更重要。我总是鼓励人们这样说：你知道的，一旦你听完了对方的话，首先，总结你从他们那里听到的话，以便真正表明你听进去了，然后改用“和”这个词，直接说：“而且，你知道的，这是我的观点，或者这是我的担忧、我的视角。”现在，你所说的意思是，对方可能会为此感到不安，或者有点，你知道的，
it might go off the rails a little bit. Yes. And guess what that would tell you that this person may have some difficulty with perspective taking or emotion regulation skills? Or they may have just had a lot of plan A interactions and assume that right after you've heard them, here comes plan A. So, you know, it's not magic. It's going to take some repetition. Again, collaborative problem solving has three big steps. First, empathize with the other party's concerns. Once you've understood where they're coming from, and they agree you have understood their point of view,
it might go off the rails a little bit. Yes. And guess what that would tell you that this person may have some difficulty with perspective taking or emotion regulation skills? Or they may have just had a lot of plan A interactions and assume that right after you've heard them, here comes plan A. So, you know, it's not magic. It's going to take some repetition. Again, collaborative problem solving has three big steps. First, empathize with the other party's concerns. Once you've understood where they're coming from, and they agree you have understood their point of view,|||事情可能会有点偏离正轨？是的。你猜这会告诉你什么？这说明这个人可能在换位思考或情绪调节技能方面存在一些困难？或者他们可能经历过太多次A计划式的互动，并认为就在你听完他们说话之后，A计划就要登场了。所以，你知道的，这不是魔法。这需要一些重复。再说一次，协作解决问题有三大步骤。第一，对对方的担忧产生同理心。一旦你理解了他们的出发点，并且他们也认同你已经理解了他们的观点，
you say, and here's my perspective. Here are my concerns. When it comes to the third step, which is coming up with a collaborative solution, Stuart says it's important not to make the first move. Once you've clarified the problem to solve, which is once you've identified the respective concerns, there's a lot of reasons you want to invite the other person to take first crack at solutions. First of all, when you invite that person to come up with an idea, you are giving them
you say, and here's my perspective. Here are my concerns. When it comes to the third step, which is coming up with a collaborative solution, Stuart says it's important not to make the first move. Once you've clarified the problem to solve, which is once you've identified the respective concerns, there's a lot of reasons you want to invite the other person to take first crack at solutions. First of all, when you invite that person to come up with an idea, you are giving them|||你就说：“而且，这是我的视角。这些是我的担忧。”至于第三步，即提出一个协作性的解决方案，斯图尔特说，重要的一点是不要抢先行动。一旦你明确了要解决的问题，也就是一旦你确定了各自的担忧，你希望邀请对方率先尝试提出解决方案，这背后有很多原因。首先，当你邀请那个人想出一个主意时，你赋予了他们
ownership, autonomy. They're co-author of a solution, as opposed to you sort of, even if you're trying to do it in the best of collaborative spirits, if you're the one suggesting the first solution, might feel imposed upon them. And if they're co-author, they're going to be much more invested in that. But beyond that, you know, this is an opportunity to actually get a chance to see how that person does, what their skills are like coming up with a solution that is theoretically mutually satisfactory, realistic and doable. I work with lots of people who they'll come up with a solution, but it's not mutually
ownership, autonomy. They're co-author of a solution, as opposed to you sort of, even if you're trying to do it in the best of collaborative spirits, if you're the one suggesting the first solution, might feel imposed upon them. And if they're co-author, they're going to be much more invested in that. But beyond that, you know, this is an opportunity to actually get a chance to see how that person does, what their skills are like coming up with a solution that is theoretically mutually satisfactory, realistic and doable. I work with lots of people who they'll come up with a solution, but it's not mutually|||所有权和自主权。他们是一个解决方案的共同缔造者，而不是像你那样——即使你本着最好的合作精神去做——如果你是提出第一个解决方案的人，他们可能会觉得这是强加给他们的。而如果他们是共同缔造者，他们就会投入得多得多。不仅如此，你知道的，这是一个真正的机会，可以借此观察这个人的表现如何，看看他们提出理论上对双方都满意、现实且可行的解决方案时，其技能水平如何。我合作过很多人，他们会想出一个解决方案，但这并不是双方都满意的，
satisfactory, or it's not realistic, or it's not doable. And so they need practice. Well, guess how you're going to practice and develop that skill? Not by watching somebody else solve problems. I mean, when you teach a kid to ride a bike, do you hop on the bike and say, all right, watch me ride. You got it? Here you go.
satisfactory, or it's not realistic, or it's not doable. And so they need practice. Well, guess how you're going to practice and develop that skill? Not by watching somebody else solve problems. I mean, when you teach a kid to ride a bike, do you hop on the bike and say, all right, watch me ride. You got it? Here you go.|||或者它不切实际，或者根本行不通。因此他们需要练习。好吧，你猜你要怎么去练习和发展这项技能？不是通过看别人解决问题。我的意思是，当你教孩子骑自行车时，你会跳上自行车说：“好了，看我骑。学会了吗？给你。”
You should be good now. No, watching someone else come up with ideas doesn't help somebody practice and develop problem solving skills. I think some people might hear this approach, Stewart, and say, all right, this is actually perhaps a clever way into manipulating this other person to doing. what I really want them to do. So I listen to them very carefully. I offer them my perspective. I let them come up with the idea. And all the while, I'm trying to keep in mind what it is that I finally want, the outcome that I finally want, and try and push a nudge to get to that
You should be good now. No, watching someone else come up with ideas doesn't help somebody practice and develop problem solving skills. I think some people might hear this approach, Stewart, and say, all right, this is actually perhaps a clever way into manipulating this other person to doing. what I really want them to do. So I listen to them very carefully. I offer them my perspective. I let them come up with the idea. And all the while, I'm trying to keep in mind what it is that I finally want, the outcome that I finally want, and try and push a nudge to get to that|||“你现在应该没问题了吧。”不，看别人想出主意并不能帮助某人练习和培养解决问题的技能。斯图尔特，我想有些人听到这种方法可能会说：好吧，这其实可能是一种巧妙的方法，用来操纵另一个人去做我真正想让他们做的事。所以我非常仔细地听他们说话，向他们提供我的视角，让他们自己想出主意。而与此同时，我一直在心里想着我最终想要的是什么、我最终想要的结果是什么，并试图推一把、暗示一下以达到那个
outcome. It's just sort of a sneaky psychological way of getting to what I want in the first place. I think you're actually suggesting something different, that in fact, collaborative problem solving is not just a backdoor way into manipulating someone to get what you want all along? Not at all. In fact, I would call that tricky plan A, not plan B. Because a really important distinction here is you actually shouldn't know what the solution is going to be. If you already know what the solution is and you're just trying to get the person there, yeah, that's plan A. That's just a tricky form of plan A. Now, what you need to do is you need to think of what is your concern? What are you worried about? What's your point of view? What is wanting
outcome. It's just sort of a sneaky psychological way of getting to what I want in the first place? I think you're actually suggesting something different, that in fact, collaborative problem solving is not just a backdoor way into manipulating someone to get what you want all along? Not at all. In fact, I would call that tricky plan A, not plan B. Because a really important distinction here is you actually shouldn't know what the solution is going to be. If you already know what the solution is and you're just trying to get the person there, yeah, that's plan A. That's just a tricky form of plan A. Now, what you need to do is you need to think of what is your concern? What are you worried about? What's your point of view? What is wanting|||结果。这只是一种偷偷摸摸的心理手段，用来达到我一开始就想要的东西吗？我想你其实是在暗示一些不同的东西，事实上，协作解决问题并不仅仅是操纵某人以获得你一直想要的东西的后门途径？完全不是。事实上，我会把那称作狡猾的A计划，而不是B计划。因为这里有一个非常重要的区别：你其实不应该事先知道解决方案会是什么。如果你已经知道了解决方案，而你只是在设法让对方走到那一步，是的，那就是A计划。那只是A计划的一种狡猾形式。现在，你需要做的是思考：你的担忧是什么？你在担心什么？你的观点是什么？是什么促使
you to come up with that solution? What are you worried about? And you hold on tight. to that. You don't relinquish that. And the solution has to address your concern. But it also has to address the other party's concern. That's the difference. That's collaborative problem solving. And of course, partly what all of this is pointing to Stewart is humility. Because I think very often, I think when we're trying to change someone, we are so confident that we know why they're not doing what they should be doing. We're so confident that we know what they should be doing and how they should be doing it, that one reason we don't stop to actually ask, well, what's going on in your head, what could be happening in your mind, is that we don't have
you to come up with that solution? What are you worried about? And you hold on tight. to that. You don't relinquish that. And the solution has to address your concern. But it also has to address the other party's concern. That's the difference. That's collaborative problem solving. And of course, partly what all of this is pointing to Stewart is humility. Because I think very often, I think when we're trying to change someone, we are so confident that we know why they're not doing what they should be doing. We're so confident that we know what they should be doing and how they should be doing it, that one reason we don't stop to actually ask, well, what's going on in your head, what could be happening in your mind, is that we don't have|||你想出那个解决方案？你在担心什么？你要紧紧抓住这一点。你不能放弃这一点。解决方案必须解决你的担忧。但它也必须解决另一方的担忧。这就是区别所在。这才是协作解决问题。当然，所有这一切在某种程度上都指向了一个词，斯图尔特，那就是谦逊。因为我认为很多时候，当我们试图改变某人时，我们是如此自信地认为我们知道他们为什么没有做他们该做的事。我们如此自信地认为我们知道他们应该做什么以及应该如何去做，以至于我们停下来去问一句“好吧，你脑子里在想什么，你心里可能在发生什么”的原因之一，就是我们没有
the humility to accept that, in fact, we might not have all the answers ourselves. That's right. That's right. And when we can suspend those assumptions and be really curious, we learn so much. And not only do we learn so much, but it really connects us to people. People ask me that all their time. They say, how do you really get somebody to listen to you? I say, by listening to them. Listen to them really hard, really well, really effectively, and they'll be a whole lot more likely to listen to you. When we come back, collaborative problem solving in action.
the humility to accept that, in fact, we might not have all the answers ourselves. That's right. That's right. And when we can suspend those assumptions and be really curious, we learn so much. And not only do we learn so much, but it really connects us to people. People ask me that all their time. They say, how do you really get somebody to listen to you? I say, by listening to them. Listen to them really hard, really well, really effectively, and they'll be a whole lot more likely to listen to you. When we come back, collaborative problem solving in action.|||谦逊去接受这样一个事实：事实上，我们自己可能并没有所有的答案。没错。正是如此。当我们能够悬置这些假设并保持真正的好奇心时，我们会学到很多东西。不仅我们能学到很多，而且这确实将我们与他人联系在了一起。人们总是问我这个问题。他们说：“你到底怎样才能让别人听你的？”我说：“通过倾听他们。”非常努力地、非常好地、极其有效地倾听他们，他们就极有可能听你的。稍后回来，我们将为您呈现协作解决问题的实际应用。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Whether it's an unruly child, a spouse who forgets important dates, or a co-worker who says inappropriate things at meetings, it can be hard to get people to behave the way you want them to. Psychologist Stuart Ablon says the solution is collaborative problem solving, coming to mutually agreeable solutions together. One of the places he tested his ideas was a state psychiatric hospital. It was infamous because it was the setting for a disturbing movie about the mistreatment of patients.
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Whether it's an unruly child, a spouse who forgets important dates, or a co-worker who says inappropriate things at meetings, it can be hard to get people to behave the way you want them to. Psychologist Stuart Ablon says the solution is collaborative problem solving, coming to mutually agreeable solutions together. One of the places he tested his ideas was a state psychiatric hospital. It was infamous because it was the setting for a disturbing movie about the mistreatment of patients.|||您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。无论是不守规矩的孩子、忘记重要日子的配偶，还是在会议上说不当言论的同事，想让人们按你的意愿行事往往很难。心理学家斯图尔特·阿布隆表示，解决方法是协作解决问题，即共同商定双方都同意的解决方案。他测试其理念的场所之一是一家州立精神病院。该医院臭名昭著，因为它是描写虐待患者的不安电影的取景地。
I always tell people the Oregon State Hospital. I ask people, do you know it? Everybody says no. And I said, well, actually, you do. Because it was featured in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest. Now, that original hospital has been torn down. There's a beautiful, big, hulking, new hospital. but I have to tell you from having spent some time there, the sort of traumas of the past
I always tell people the Oregon State Hospital. I ask people, do you know it? Everybody says no. And I said, well, actually, you do. Because it was featured in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest. Now, that original hospital has been torn down. There's a beautiful, big, hulking, new hospital. but I have to tell you from having spent some time there, the sort of traumas of the past|||我总是跟人提起俄勒冈州立医院。我问大家：“你们知道它吗？”所有人都说不知道。我说：“嗯，其实你们知道。”因为它曾在电影《飞越疯人院》中出现过。如今，那家最初的医院已经被拆除。那里耸立着一座美丽、庞大、崭新的医院。但我必须告诉你，根据我在那里呆过一段时间的经历，过去的种种创伤
almost echo through the walls there. And we were contacted because staff were being assaulted at alarming rates and all kinds of injuries of their patients, the clients there, and the staff as well. I remember at one point the staff had actually set up a Facebook page to post the pictures of their injuries to try to get people to pay attention to that something was really wrong here. Wow. And we were brought in to try to change that dynamic. So when you call this a hospital, you know, the image that I have is sort of doctors and nurses walking around and people holding charts. That's not quite the right picture, is it, Stuart?
almost echo through the walls there. And we were contacted because staff were being assaulted at alarming rates and all kinds of injuries of their patients, the clients there, and the staff as well. I remember at one point the staff had actually set up a Facebook page to post the pictures of their injuries to try to get people to pay attention to that something was really wrong here. Wow. And we were brought in to try to change that dynamic. So when you call this a hospital, you know, the image that I have is sort of doctors and nurses walking around and people holding charts. That's not quite the right picture, is it, Stuart?|||几乎还在那里的墙壁间回响。我们被联系上，是因为工作人员遭到袭击的比率惊人，病人们——那里的服务对象以及工作人员都受到了各种各样的伤害。我记得有一次，工作人员甚至建立了一个脸书（Facebook）页面，用来发布他们受伤的照片，以此试图引起人们的注意：这里真的出了大问题。哇。我们被请去试图改变这种动态。所以，当你把这称为一家医院时，你知道的，我脑海中的画面基本上是医生和护士走来走去，人们拿着病历表。这并不是一幅准确的画面，对吗，斯图尔特？
No, this is a state psychiatric hospital with over a thousand patients, but the vast majority. of them are guilty, if not for insanity. So they are there for having committed rather serious crimes. And, you know, it's somewhere between what you might think of as a hospital, but probably closer to what a correctional facility looks like. You know, you've got to be buzzed in and out of several doors to get in there. It's maximum security. You know, the restrooms have a fixed toilet with nothing that could be ripped off and used as. a weapon or anything like that. It's a pretty tough place. So the hospital wanted to improve conditions. I would have imagined that this would be a
No, this is a state psychiatric hospital with over a thousand patients, but the vast majority. of them are guilty, if not for insanity. So they are there for having committed rather serious crimes. And, you know, it's somewhere between what you might think of as a hospital, but probably closer to what a correctional facility looks like. You know, you've got to be buzzed in and out of several doors to get in there. It's maximum security. You know, the restrooms have a fixed toilet with nothing that could be ripped off and used as. a weapon or anything like that. It's a pretty tough place. So the hospital wanted to improve conditions. I would have imagined that this would be a|||不，这是一是一家拥有上千名患者的州立精神病院，但绝大多数患者即使不是因为精神错乱而被判有罪，也是因犯罪入册。所以他们在那儿是因为犯下了相当严重的罪行。而且，你知道的，它介于你可能认为的医院和更接近惩教所的外观之间。你知道的，进出那里必须通过蜂鸣器开启多道门。那是最高安全级别。你知道的，洗手间里有固定马桶，没有任何东西是可以被拆下来当作武器之类使用的。那是个相当严酷的地方。所以医院想要改善条件。我本以为这会是一个
difficult place to think about collaborative problem solving. Describe for me the work that you did and what you found. Well, you're right. It is a difficult place, was a difficult place. But I have to say, I found a decent amount of receptivity there from folks because, you know, it's people who work in those situations that know firsthand that levying rewards and punishments really is not very effective and creates all kinds of hostility and makes for a pretty miserable job. So they were eager to learn something else, but I will also say skeptical and for good reason. And so it took a little while to really have people begin to shift their mindsets because you can't come right in and just teach people a new way of doing things. You first have to help them understand why would you do something differently in the first place? And that's that shift from it's not as simple as people do well if they want to. We just got to make them want to. It's people do well
difficult place to think about collaborative problem solving. Describe for me the work that you did and what you found. Well, you're right. It is a difficult place, was a difficult place. But I have to say, I found a decent amount of receptivity there from folks because, you know, it's people who work in those situations that know firsthand that levying rewards and punishments really is not very effective and creates all kinds of hostility and makes for a pretty miserable job. So they were eager to learn something else, but I will also say skeptical and for good reason. And so it took a little while to really have people begin to shift their mindsets because you can't come right in and just teach people a new way of doing things. You first have to help them understand why would you do something differently in the first place? And that's that shift from it's not as simple as people do well if they want to. We just got to make them want to. It's people do well|||很难让人联想到协作解决问题的地方。请向我描述一下你所做的工作以及你的发现。嗯，你说的对。这是一个困难的地方，曾经是一个困难的地方。但我必须说，我在那里从人们身上发现了相当高的接受度，因为，你知道的，正是那些在那种环境下工作的人，才亲身体会到实施奖惩其实并没有太大效果，反而会制造各种敌意，并让这份工作变得相当痛苦。所以他们渴望学习其他方法，但我也要说，他们也抱有怀疑态度，而且这种怀疑是有充分理由的。因此，花了点时间才真正让人们开始转变心态，因为你不能一走进去就教给人们一种做事的新方法。你首先必须帮助他们理解：你凭什么要以不同的方式做事？这就是那种心态的转变：事情并不像“人们只要愿意就能做得很好，我们只需要让他们愿意”那么简单。事实是：人们之所以能做好，
if they can. And we have a lot of research that shows these people are here because they're struggling with a lack of skill, not a lack of will. So you told us, story of one middle-aged patient who suffered from a history of schizophrenia. Tell me his story, Stuart. This was a man who had actually been refusing to attend any of the therapeutic elements of the program. So they would, you know, the patients would stay in their cell blocks, but they would come down to what they called the treatment mall to have individual and group therapy. And this guy would refuse to come down there. Now, you can imagine what they would typically try. They would typically try some form of plan A to try to impose their will to get him down there, which is if you don't
if they can. And we have a lot of research that shows these people are here because they're struggling with a lack of skill, not a lack of will. So you told us, story of one middle-aged patient who suffered from a history of schizophrenia. Tell me his story, Stuart. This was a man who had actually been refusing to attend any of the therapeutic elements of the program. So they would, you know, the patients would stay in their cell blocks, but they would come down to what they called the treatment mall to have individual and group therapy. And this guy would refuse to come down there. Now, you can imagine what they would typically try. They would typically try some form of plan A to try to impose their will to get him down through, which is if you don't|||是因为他们有能力做到。我们有大量的研究表明，这些人之所以来到这里，是因为他们在技能上有所欠缺，而不是缺乏意志。所以你跟我们讲过一个患有精神分裂症病史的中年患者的故事。斯图尔特，请讲讲他的故事。这个人其实一直拒绝参加该项目中的任何治疗环节。所以他们会——你知道的，病人们会呆在各自的牢房区，但他们会来到被称为“治疗购物中心”的地方参加个人和团体治疗。而这家伙拒绝下来。现在，你可以想象他们通常会尝试什么方法。他们通常会尝试某种形式的A计划，试图强行将他们的意志强加于他，让他下来。也就是说，如果你不
come, you will lose this privilege, et cetera. If you do, you get these privileges. And believe it or not, the hospital itself was designed around these principles. Even the building, the building has a store that was built where people could, you know, accrue rewards and things like that. So they had tried this, and frankly, it got ugly. There were several assaults trying to get this rather large man down to the treatment mall. And so what they started to do was plan C, which is say, you know what, it's just not worth all of this. So, you know, I guess he won't attend. And we began to teach them what an alternative would look like, what plan B, collaborative problem solving would look like.
come, you will lose this privilege, et cetera. If you do, you get these privileges. And believe it or not, the hospital itself was designed around these principles. Even the building, the building has a store that was built where people could, you know, accrue rewards and things like that. So they had tried this, and frankly, it got ugly. There were several assaults trying to get this rather large man down to the treatment mall. And so what they started to do was plan C, which is say, you know what, it's just not worth all of this. So, you know, I guess he won't attend. And we began to teach them what an alternative would look like, what plan B, collaborative problem solving would look like.|||来，你就会失去这个特权等等。如果你来了，你就能获得这些特权。信不信由你，这家医院本身就是围绕这些原则设计的。甚至连建筑也是如此，建筑里建了一家商店，人们可以在那里，你知道的，积累奖励之类。所以他们尝试过这种方法，坦白说，结果变得很糟糕。为了让这个体型相当庞大的男人下楼去治疗中心，曾发生过好几起袭击事件。于是他们开始采取C计划，也就是觉得：“你知道吗，这实在不值得付出这么大代价。所以，好吧，我想他不会参加了。”然后我们开始教导他们替代方案会是什么样子，B计划——协作解决问题会是什么样子。
and this one nurse decided to try plan B with him. And by the way, one important distinction here is there's a difference between what I like to call emergency collaborative problem solving and proactive collaborative problem solving. The best time to solve a problem is not right in the middle of it. So it's not when you're trying to force this guy to go to the treatment mall. So she sits down with him and says, hey, so I've noticed you haven't been going to groups. She knew he was very volatile, so she front-loaded with reassurance. Don't worry, I'm not going to try to force you to go to group.
and this one nurse decided to try plan B with him. And by the way, one important distinction here is there's a difference between what I like to call emergency collaborative problem solving and proactive collaborative problem solving. The best time to solve a problem is not right in the middle of it. So it's not when you're trying to force this guy to go to the treatment mall. So she sits down with him and says, hey, so I've noticed you haven't been going to groups. She knew he was very volatile, so she front-loaded with reassurance. Don't worry, I'm not going to try to force you to go to group.|||然后，有位护士决定尝试对这个人使用B计划。顺便说一句，这里有一个重要的区别：我喜欢称之为“紧急协作解决问题”和“前瞻性协作解决问题”，这两者之间是有区别的。解决问题的最佳时机不是在问题爆发的当口。所以，那不是当你试图强迫这家伙去治疗中心的时候。于是她坐下来对他说：“嘿，我注意到你一直没去参加小组活动。”她知道他的情绪很不稳定，所以她预先给予了安慰。“别担心，我不会试图强迫你去参加小组活动。
That's not what this conversation is about, basically saying, you know, this is not plan A. I just want to understand. I bet you have a really good reason why you're not going. Can you tell me? And, of course, he thinks this is still plan A. What does he do? He says, you're not going to make me go. You just try.
That's not what this conversation is about, basically saying, you know, this is not plan A. I just want to understand. I bet you have a really good reason why you're not going. Can you tell me? And, of course, he thinks this is still plan A. What does he do? He says, you're not going to make me go. You just try.|||这不是这次谈话的目的。”基本上是说，你知道的，这不是A计划。“我只是想了解情况。我敢说你一定有一个非常好的理由才不去的。能告诉我吗？”当然，他认为这仍然是A计划。他会怎么做？他说：“你别想让我去。你尽管试试。”
You're not going to make me. She goes right to reflective listening. I'm not going to. You're absolutely right. I'm not going to. Okay. And I'm sure you have a good reason why you're not going to. going, more reassurance. And I'm just curious. I bet there's a good reason. I just wonder if you
You're not going to make me. She goes right to reflective listening. I'm not going to. You're absolutely right. I'm not going to. Okay. And I'm sure you have a good reason why you're not going. going, more reassurance. And I'm just curious. I bet there's a good reason. I just wonder if you|||“你强迫不了我。”她直接转向了反思性倾听。“我不会强迫你。你说得对极了，我不会强迫你。好的。而且我确信你一定有充分的理由才不去的。”更多的安慰。“我只是好奇。我敢说一定有个好理由。我只是想知道你
could help me understand. And he said, I'm not going and sit in some little room with a bunch of people. She goes right to reflective listening. Anytime you hear something is a good detective, go to reflective listening and then look for more. So she says, so you don't want to go sit in a room with a bunch of people, a small room. How come? Because I'm not going to do it. You're not going to make me. You're absolutely right. I'm not going to make you. I just want to understand. And it sounds like there's something about being in a small room with people? Yeah, because they can hear my every thought. Oh, they can hear your every thought.
could help me understand. And he said, I'm not going and sit in some little room with a bunch of people. She goes right to reflective listening. Anytime you hear something is a good detective, go to reflective listening and then look for more. So she says, so you don't want to go sit in a room with a bunch of people, a small room. How come? Because I'm not going to do it. You're not going to make me. You're absolutely right. I'm not going to make you. I just want to understand. And it sounds like there's something about being in a small room with people? Yeah, because they can hear my every thought. Oh, they can hear your every thought.|||能不能帮我理解一下。”他说：“我才不要去跟一堆人挤在某个小房间里坐着呢。”她立刻转入反思性倾听。每当你听到某些信息时，就像一个优秀的侦探那样，先进行反思性倾听，然后再寻找更多信息。于是她说：“所以你不想去跟一群人坐在一个房间里，一个很小的房间。为什么呢？”“因为我才不干。你别想强迫我。”“你说得完全正确。我不会强迫你的。我只是想了解一下。听起来，跟人们呆在一个小房间里有什么特别的原因吗？”“对，因为他们能听到我脑子里的每一个想法。”“哦，他们能听到你脑子里的每一个想法。”
And this, by the way, is a good example of you don't have to agree with what the person is saying to understand it. Just go to reflective listening. They can hear your every thought. How come? Because of the brain waves that are coming out of my brain. And this is an actively delusional person with paranoid schizophrenia who has a delusion that actually the FBI has planted information in his head and that other people can hear the information and things like that.
And this, by the way, is a good example of you don't have to agree with what the person is saying to understand it. Just go to reflective listening. They can hear your every thought. How come? Because of the brain waves that are coming out of my brain. And this is an actively delusional person with paranoid schizophrenia who has a delusion that actually the FBI has planted information in his head and that other people can hear the information and things like that.|||顺便说一句，这正是一个很好的例子，说明你不需要同意对方说的话也能去理解它。直接进行反思性倾听即可。“他们能听到你脑子里的每一个想法。为什么呢？”“因为从我大脑里发射出来的脑波。”这是一个患有偏执型精神分裂症、正处于妄想发作期的患者，他有一种妄想，认为实际上联邦调查局（FBI）把信息植入了自己脑中，其他人能听到这些信息等等。
And this nurse does the best job of empathizing because what she says is, oh, wow. So you're saying when people are close to you, they can hear your every thought. And so you don't want to go down into the therapy, the treatment mall and sit in a small room where everybody could hear everything you're thinking. And the guy's like, yeah, would you want everybody hearing what you're thinking?
And this nurse does the best job of empathizing because what she says is, oh, wow. So you're saying when people are close to you, they can hear your every thought. And so you don't want to go down into the therapy, the treatment mall and sit in a small room where everybody could hear everything you're thinking. And the guy's like, yeah, would you want everybody hearing what you're thinking?|||而这位护士把同理心做得极其到位，因为她说：“哦，哇。你是说，当别人靠近你时，他们能听到你的每一个想法。所以你才不想去治疗中心，不想坐在一个所有人都能听到你心里所有想法的小房间里？”那家伙说：“对啊，难道你愿意让所有人都听到你在想什么吗？”
And she says, absolutely not. so she doesn't have to agree but now she's understanding where he's coming from and he's beginning to regulate because she's understanding him that's ingredient one she moves on to ingredient two after summarizing so it sounds like you're not wanting to go down to the treatment mall because you don't want everybody here your every thought which i can totally understand i wouldn't want everybody here in my every thought either and not but she says and i guess i just worried that then you don't get to participate in and benefit from any of the treatment. He thinks she's about to go plan A. So what does he do? He said, you're not going to make me go. She goes right back with a little reassurance. You're absolutely
And she says, absolutely not. so she doesn't have to agree but now she's understanding where he's coming from and he's beginning to regulate because she's understanding him that's ingredient one she moves on to ingredient two after summarizing so it sounds like you're not wanting to go down to the treatment mall because you don't want everybody here your every thought which i can totally understand i wouldn't want everybody here in my every thought either and not but she says and i guess i just worried that then you don't get to participate in and benefit from any of the treatment. He thinks she's about to go plan A. So what does he do? He said, you're not going to make me go. She goes right back with a little reassurance. You're absolutely|||她说：“当然不愿意。”所以她不需要同意他的观点，但现在她理解了他的出发点，而由于她理解了他，他也开始平静下来了。这是第一要素。在总结之后，她进入了第二要素：“所以听起来，你不想去治疗中心，是因为你不想让所有人听到你的每一个想法，我完全能理解，如果是我，我也不希望所有人听到我心里的每一个想法。而且不——”但接着她说：“不过我只是担心，这样一来你就无法参与并从中受益于任何治疗了。”他以为她马上要祭出A计划了。于是他做了什么？他说：“你休想强迫我去。”她立刻用一点安慰作为回应：“你说得完全
right. I'm not going to force you to go. That would be dumb. Why would I want to force you to go somewhere where you say everybody can hear your every thought? That sounds terrible. I don't want to make you do that. I'm just worried that you're not able to benefit from the treatment. Two sets of concerns on the table, ready to go to the third ingredient. So I wonder if there's a way that you could benefit from the treatment groups and not have to worry about anybody hearing your every thought because that sounds terrible. And then just what we said, ask him to take first crack at a solution. Do you have any ideas what we could do? She waits a little bit and he says, I got an idea. What's your idea? I could put tinfoil on my head. And she does just what we teach people to do,
right. I'm not going to force you to go. That would be dumb. Why would I want to force you to go somewhere where you say everybody can hear your every thought? That sounds terrible. I don't want to make you do that. I'm just worried that you're not able to benefit from the treatment. Two sets of concerns on the table, ready to go to the third ingredient. So I wonder if there's a way that you could benefit from the treatment groups and not have to worry about anybody hearing your every thought because that sounds terrible. And then just what we said, ask him to take first crack at a solution. Do you have any ideas what we could do? She waits a little bit and he says, I got an idea. What's your idea? I could put tinfoil on my head. And she does just what we teach people to do,|||对了。我才不会强迫你去呢。那太蠢了。我怎么会想强迫你去一个你所说的“所有人都能听到你每一个想法”的地方呢？听起来太可怕了。我不想让你做那种事。我只是担心你无法从治疗中受益。”两套担忧都摆上了台面，准备进入第三要素。“所以我想知道，有没有什么办法能让你既能从治疗小组中受益，又不必担心任何人听到你心里的每个想法——因为听起来那太可怕了。”然后就像我们所说的那样，请他率先尝试提出一个解决方案：“对于我们能做点什么，你有什么想法吗？”她等了一会儿，他说：“我有个主意。”“你有什么主意？”“我可以在头上包锡箔纸。”她做出了我们教导人们要做的反应，
which is to respond to any idea by saying that's an idea, let's think about it together. So you put tinfoil on your head. That would like help with the brainwaves. Yeah, that would block them so nobody could hear what I was saying. Uh-huh. So you would then go to the group? Well, if it worked, yeah, I would go. Huh. Well, and do you think we could do that? And he's like, I've seen the tinfoil you have in the kitchen. And would it cause any problems? I don't think so. And she says, well, I'm a little worried about the other folks might think it's a little odd or, you know, make fun of you or something like that. And he laughs and he says, no, no, no, no, no.
which is to respond to any idea by saying that's an idea, let's think about it together. So you put tinfoil on your head. That would like help with the brainwaves. Yeah, that would block them so nobody could hear what I was saying. Uh-huh. So you would then go to the group? Well, if it worked, yeah, I would go. Huh. Well, and do you think we could do that? And he's like, I've seen the tinfoil you have in the kitchen. And would it cause any problems? I don't think so. And she says, well, I'm a little worried about the other folks might think it's a little odd or, you know, make fun of you or something like that. And he laughs and he says, no, no, no, no, no.|||即对任何主意都这样回应：“这倒是个主意，让我们一起来想想看。”“所以你在头上包锡箔纸。那会对脑波有所帮助吗？”“对，那会挡住它们，这样就没人能听到我在说什么了。”“噢。那你会去参加小组活动吗？”“嗯，如果管用的的话，会的，我会去。”“哼。好吧，那你觉得我们能这样做吗？”他接着说：“我见过你们厨房里的锡箔纸。”“那会引起什么问题吗？”“我觉得不会。”她说：“嗯，我有点担心其他人可能会觉得这有点奇怪，或者，你知道的，拿你开玩笑什么的。”他笑着说：“不，不，不，不，不。
I'm not going to just have the tinfoil on my head. We can put it, like, on my head, but then I'll put my beanie on. So only you and I will know that it's under there. And, you know, there you have it. What do you have? You have a solution where who wins there? Everybody. Who loses?
I'm not going to just have the tinfoil on my head. We can put it, like, on my head, but then I'll put my beanie on. So only you and I will know that it's under there. And, you know, there you have it. What do you have? You have a solution where who wins there? Everybody. Who loses?|||我不会只把锡箔纸顶在头上的。我们可以把它，比如说，戴在我头上，然后我再戴上毛线帽。这样只有你和我才知道它在下面。”你看，解决方案不就出来了吗？你得到了什么？你得到了一个谁是赢家的解决方案？所有人。谁输了？
Nobody. Problem solved. Relationship built. Challenging behavior decreased. And this guy who hasn't gone to try. treatment in literally years, starts going to treatment. Not magic, hard work, but three ingredients, and she did a beautiful job with it. I'm wondering if one reason we find it difficult to do this, Stuart, is that perhaps without even
Nobody. Problem solved. Relationship built. Challenging behavior decreased. And this guy who hasn't gone to try. treatment in literally years, starts going to treatment. Not magic, hard work, but three ingredients, and she did a beautiful job with it. I'm wondering if one reason we find it difficult to do this, Stuart, is that perhaps without even|||没有人。问题解决了。关系建立起来了。挑衅行为减少了。这个已经好几年没去尝试治疗的家伙，开始去接受治疗了。这不是魔法，这是艰苦的工作，但这有三个要素，而且她做得非常出色。斯图尔特，我在想，我们发现自己很难做到这一点的一个原因，是不是也许甚至在我们自己都没
articulating it to ourselves, we very often don't just want people to change, but we want people to change for our reasons. Yes. And, you know, here's the thing. It's okay for you to have your reasons for why you want them to change. But that can't be the only thing that needs to be taken into account. I mean, she had her own reasons in this case. Her reasons were, I'm a nurse. This is a psychiatric hospital. I want you to get treatment. It's okay for her to not only have those, but to pursue them. but his concerns have to have equal weight as well. And I think that's the beauty of collaborative problem solving. It's not that you need to relinquish your concerns or your desires.
articulating it to ourselves, we very often don't just want people to change, but we want people to change for our reasons. Yes. And, you know, here's the thing. It's okay for you to have your reasons for why you want them to change. But that can't be the only thing that needs to be taken into account. I mean, she had her own reasons in this case. Her reasons were, I'm a nurse. This is a psychiatric hospital. I want you to get treatment. It's okay for her to not only have those, but to pursue them. but his concerns have to have equal weight as well. And I think that's the beauty of collaborative problem solving. It's not that you need to relinquish your concerns or your desires.|||意识到的时候，我们往往不仅希望别人改变，而且我们希望别人为了我们的理由而改变？是的。你知道的，事情是这样的：你希望他们改变有你自己的理由，这是可以的。但这不能是唯一需要考虑的因素。我的意思是，在这个案例中，她有她自己的理由。她的理由是：我是一名护士。这里是精神病院。我希望你接受治疗。她不仅可以拥有这些理由，还可以去追求它们，这是没问题的。但他的担忧也必须具有同等的分量。我认为这正是协作解决问题的精妙之处。你不需要放弃你的担忧或你的愿望。
You don't have to. You can pursue them, but that can't be the only thing you're pursuing or else you're doing that tricky form of plan A. You've done some research looking at the effectiveness of using collaborative problem solving on the skills that people develop. One of the studies you conducted was at a children's center in Ottawa. Tell me what you found, Stuart. Yeah, so, you know, I'm talking here
You don't have to. You can pursue them, but that can't be the only thing you're pursuing or else you're doing that tricky form of plan A. You've done some research looking at the effectiveness of using collaborative problem solving on the skills that people develop. One of the studies you conducted was at a children's center in Ottawa. Tell me what you found, Stuart. Yeah, so, you know, I'm talking here|||你不需要这样做。你可以去追求它们，但那不能是你唯一追求的东西，否则你就是在搞那种狡猾的A计划。你做过一些研究，探讨使用协作解决问题对人们所发展的技能的有效性。你开展的一项研究是在渥太华的一个儿童中心进行的。斯图尔特，请告诉我你发现了什么。是的，所以，你知道的，我在这里谈论的是
about solving problems, decreasing, challenging behavior, improving relationships, but the other thing is skill building. And what we found in this study in Ottawa, for instance, is that kids who received collaborative problem solving, the adults in their lives were using collaborative problem solving, those kids not only did their behaviors, their challenging behaviors, decrease more substantially compared to kids across the province who were treated with other approaches, but the kids started
about solving problems, decreasing, challenging behavior, improving relationships, but the other thing is skill building. And what we found in this study in Ottawa, for instance, is that kids who received collaborative problem solving, the adults in their lives were using collaborative problem solving, those kids not only did their behaviors, their challenging behaviors, decrease more substantially compared to kids across the province who were treated with other approaches, but the kids started|||解决问题、减少挑衅行为、改善人际关系，但另一件事是技能培养。比如我们在渥太华的这项研究所发现的：接受了协作解决问题的孩子——他们生活中的成年人在使用协作解决问题——与全省接受其他方法治疗的孩子相比，这些孩子的行为、挑衅行为不仅减少得更加显着，而且孩子们开始
to develop skills, self-regulation skills, like impulse control, cognitive flexibility skills. The things that we talked about are they started to develop those skills. So it's not just about solving problems in a more compassionate, effective way. it's also about building skills. Talk about the benefits for the people who are doing the intervening, the parent, the manager, the friend, not just for the person who's receiving the intervention. So this is one of my favorite findings from our research group. Our program where we do this work is based in the Department of Psychiatry at Mass General
to develop skills, self-regulation skills, like impulse control, cognitive flexibility skills. The things that we talked about are they started to develop those skills. So it's not just about solving problems in a more compassionate, effective way. it's also about building skills. Talk about the benefits for the people who are doing the intervening, the parent, the manager, the friend, not just for the person who's receiving the intervention. So this is one of my favorite findings from our research group. Our program where we do this work is based in the Department of Psychiatry at Mass General|||发展出各种技能，例如自我调节技能、冲动控制能力、认知灵活性技能。我们讨论过的那些东西——他们开始培养出这些技能了。所以，这不仅仅是以一种更有同情心、更有效的方式去解决问题，这也是关于技能的培养。请谈谈对于实施干预的人——父母、管理者、朋友——而不是仅仅对于接受干预的人来说，有哪些益处。这是我们研究小组最喜欢的发现之一。我们开展这项工作的项目基地设在麻省总医院的精神病学系，
Hospital, which is a big research institution. We study everything. It was exciting to see that kids develop skills when adults use this process and practice with them. But perhaps the most exciting thing is, as you're alluding to here, guess who else starts to develop those very same skills when they utilize this process with kids or adults for that matter? So in other words, when parents learn how to do this, they start to become better problem solvers. They develop better perspective-taking skills, better empathizing skills, more cognitive flexibility, which is great news for people like us, because what it says is,
Hospital, which is a big research institution. We study everything. It was exciting to see that kids develop skills when adults use this process and practice with them. But perhaps the most exciting thing is, as you're alluding to here, guess who else starts to develop those very same skills when they utilize this process with kids or adults for that matter? So in other words, when parents learn how to do this, they start to become better problem solvers. They develop better perspective-taking skills, better empathizing skills, more cognitive flexibility, which is great news for people like us, because what it says is,|||那是一个大型研究机构。我们研究一切。令人兴奋的是，当成年人使用这一过程并与孩子们一起练习时，孩子们发展出了各项技能。但也许最令人兴奋的是，正如你刚才所暗示的，你猜当人们对孩子（或成年人）使用这一过程时，还有谁也开始发展出完全相同的技能？换句话说，当父母学会如何做到这一点时，他们自己也开始成为更好的问题解决者。他们培养了更好的换位思考技能、更好的同理心技能以及更高的认知灵活性，这对像我们这样的人来说是个极好的消息，因为这说明：
you know, even when the brain is less malleable, when you're an adult, when you're middle-aged like me, you can still teach an old dog new tricks. Well, what I like about what you just said is that even as we're in conversation with other people, people we're trying to help, it's also the case that in some ways these are both parties in some ways that are going through the process, right? So I think very often we imagine ourselves, let's say I'm in the role of a parent or I'm in the role of a manager, I imagine that I'm the one who's trying to influence the other person. I'm the one who's trying to change the other person. What you're really saying is that it's more
你知道的，即使大脑的可塑性降低时，当你成为成年人时，当你像我一样进入中年时，你仍然可以教老狗学新把戏。嗯，我喜欢你刚才所说的是，甚至在我们与其他人交谈时，也就是我们试图帮助的人，这也是一种情况，在某种程度上，双方都在某种程度上经历这个过程，对吧？所以我认为很多时候我们想象自己，假设我扮演父母的角色或者我扮演经理的角色，我想象我是那个试图影响另一个人的人。我是那个试图改变另一个人的人。你真正想说的是，这更多是
of a diatic relationship. Perhaps I need to work on things and I need to be curious about myself and perhaps even empathetic toward myself. Absolutely. And for instance, if you're a manager, is it very helpful to have a sense of the strengths and weaknesses of your team members across these different domains of skill? Absolutely. It is equally, if not more important for you to have a grasp on your own skills and where your strengths and weaknesses are. And as you're pointing out to, you know, be empathic with yourself. You know, when I say people do well if they can, that applies to all of us. You know, I like to remind myself and others, we're all doing the best we can at any given moment with what the world is throwing at us. And the skills were
一种双向关系。也许我需要处理一些事情，我需要对自己保持好奇，甚至可能对自己保持同理心。完全正确。例如，如果你是一名经理，在这些不同的技能领域中，对团队成员的优势和劣势有一个大致的了解是否非常有帮助？绝对是的。对于你来说，掌握自己的技能以及你的优势和劣势在哪里，同样重要，甚至更重要。正如你所指出的，你知道，对自己有同理心。你知道，当我说话时，人们如果能做到就会做得很好，这适用于我们所有人。你知道，我喜欢提醒自己和他人，在任何给定的时刻，我们都在用世界抛给我们的东西做出最好的努力。以及我们能够
able to bring to bear. And at different times in our lives, there's going to be much more than we have to handle than others. Some people have to handle much more than others. And at different times, we're going to have better or worse access to our skills. But ultimately, you know, you've got to give yourself some grace because we are all doing the best we can. I'm wondering whether you ever get pushed back from people who say, this sounds all well and good in theory. But in fact, there really are some people who are bad actors. There are people who actually are, you know, their heart is not in the right place. And being overly empathetic to them just opens you up to exploitation. Yeah, well, you know, it's interesting. I remember that
调动发挥的技能。在我们生命的不同阶段，我们需要处理的事情会比其他时候多得多。有些人必须处理比其他人多得多的事情。在不同的时间，我们对技能的运用会有好有坏。但归根结底，你知道，你必须对自己网开一面，因为我们都在尽力而为。我想知道你是否曾经遭到过人们的反对，他们说，这在理论上听起来很好。但事实上，确实有一些人是坏人。有些人实际上是，你知道，他们的心不在焉。对他们过度同理心只会让你面临被剥削的风险。是的，嗯，你知道，这很有趣。我记得
first juvenile detention facility that I worked in that I told you about earlier. When we first started working there, that was a big question that came up. And I remember the first introductory presentation about this, one of the sort of senior guards there, he said, you know, this is really interesting. I think this really does apply to about 5% of the inmates here. Not the other 95, because they're hardened criminals, but 5%, I think that's right. Somewhere three to five years later, which is about how long implementation in a system takes, I remember a conversation where he said, you know what, I want to change my calculation there. I think this applies to about 95% of the people we got here.
我之前跟你说过的那第一家我工作过的少儿拘留所。当我们刚开始在那里工作时，出现了一个重大问题。我记得关于这个的第一次介绍性演示，那里的一位高级警卫说，你知道，这真的很趣。我认为这确实适用于这里大约5%的被拘留者。不是另外的95%，因为他们是顽固的罪犯，但5%，我认为这是对的。大约三到五年后，也就是系统中实施大约需要的时间，我记得有一场对话，他说，你知道吗，我想改变我的计算。我认为这适用于我们这里大约95%的人。
Maybe 5% I'm not sure about. And perhaps those are the 5% you're asking about. But I guess what I would say is I don't think those folks were born that way. And likely one of the causes of them getting to where they got is exposure to real stress, chronic toxic stress and trauma in their lives, which is not an excuse, just to be clear. for bad behavior, but it is an explanation because we do know that exposure to chronic stress and trauma impacts brain development. And guess what it impacts? Brain development in the parts of the brain that help us with these exact skills that we are talking about with each other today. Stuart says people sometimes feel collaborative problem solving is about ignoring
也许有5%我不确定。也许这些就是你所问的5%的人。但我想我会说的是，我不认为这些人天生就是这样的。他们走到今天这一步的原因之一很可能是接触到了生活中的真正压力、慢性有毒压力和创伤，为了清楚起见，这并不是不良行为的借口，但这是一个解释，因为我们确实知道，接触慢性压力和创伤会影响大脑发育。你猜它会影响什么？大脑中帮助我们掌握今天我们互相讨论的这些确切技能的部分的发育。斯图尔特说，人们有时觉得协作解决问题就是忽视
bad behavior, being soft. People have a misconduct. that when you're doing collaborative problem solving, it sort of means anything goes or you're not setting any limits or boundaries. And that's the furthest thing from the truth. You are still setting expectations. You have boundaries. There are things that people are required to do. It's just that what you're thinking about is when they don't do those things, when there's a problem, you have more than one option or more than two options. Instead of just either trying to impose your will or forget get it, you actually have another more powerful option. But you know, I think the other thing is that people will often say to me, they'll say,
不良行为，表现得软弱。人们有一种误解，认为当你进行协作解决问题时，这有点意味着一切皆有可能，或者你没有设定任何限制或界限。而这与事实相去甚远。你仍然在设定期望。你有界限。有些事情是人们被要求去做的。只是你在思考的是，当他们不做这些事情时，当出现问题时，你就不止一种选择，或者不止两种选择。你实际上还有另一个更强大的选择，而不是仅仅试图强加你的意志或者算了吧。但是你知道，我认为另一件事是人们经常对我说，他们会说，
okay, that's fine, but how is somebody going to learn how to take responsibility for their actions? I mean, when are you going to, how are you going to hold people accountable when you do collaborative problems solving? And, you know, usually what they mean by that is like, don't you need consequences to hold people accountable and have them take responsibility? I've thought a lot about this, and I've realized that we've gotten really misguided notions around this. Like, the notion that somebody getting a consequence, that that's taking responsibility
好吧，这很好，但是怎么会有人学会为自己的行为承担责任呢？我的意思是，当你进行协作解决问题时，你什么时候打算，你将如何追究人们的责任？而且，你知道，通常他们所说的意思是，难道你不需要后果来追究人们的责任并让他们承担责任吗？我对此进行了很多思考，我意识到我们在这方面产生了非常错误的观念。比如，某人得到一个后果的概念，那是为你的行动承担责任，
for your action, just like putting up with a consequence, suffering through it, that's taking responsibility, that's being held accountable. That's like a really lame way to hold somebody accountable. And isn't ultimately the sort of most powerful way to hold somebody accountable and have them take responsibility for their actions, isn't that that person being on the hook for solving the problem so that it doesn't keep occurring? Isn't that the ultimate form of taking responsibility? I mean, in some ways, I think the model we have is almost borrowed from the criminal justice system where you say someone has done something wrong. Taking accountability means you're levying a punishment or a fine. And I suppose it makes sense in the criminal justice system because, you know,
就像忍受一个后果，痛苦地经历它，那就是承担责任，那就是被追究责任。这就像是一种非常蹩脚的方式来追究某人的责任。难道归根结底，追究某人责任并让他们为自己的行为承担责任的最强有力的方式，难道不是那个人负责解决问题以免它再次发生吗？难道这不是承担责任的终极形式吗？我的意思是，在某些情况下，我认为我们拥有的模式几乎是从刑事司法系统中借用的，在那里你说某人做错了事。承担责任意味着你正在征收惩罚或罚款。我想这在刑事司法系统中是有道理的，因为，你知道，
what options do judges have? Judges are, I'm not sure judges can do collaborative problem solving with people who come before them, but many problems in the world are not about crimes. Well, and this goes back to a larger question, which is where did our love affair with rewards and consequences come from in the first place? You know, it didn't emerge out of nowhere.
法官有什么选择？法官们，我不确定法官能否与来到他们面前的人一起解决协作问题，但世上的许多问题都与犯罪无关。嗯，这回到了一个更大的问题，那就是我们对奖励和后果的热情最初是从哪里来的？你知道，它不是凭空出现的。
When you look at like school discipline and things like that or correctional systems, where did that come from? And where it came from is from operant psychology. And what's interesting about this is there's been a ton of research on what we call contingency management approaches or token economy systems, which are like really organized ways of using rewards and consequences to try to shape behavior. And what all that research is shown is it's not like rewards and consequences are bad and you should never use them, but they're good at some things and not good at other things.
当你看看学校纪律之类的事情或惩戒系统时，那是从哪里来的？它来自操作心理学。关于这一点，有趣的是，有大量的研究针对我们所谓的权宜管理方法或代币经济系统，这些方法是非常有组织的利用奖励和后果来试图塑造行为的方式。所有这些研究都表明，奖励和后果并不是坏事，你也不应该从不使用它们，但它们在某些事情上很好，在其他事情上则不好。
They're good at reminding people what's expected of them, what's right and what's wrong, and they're good at motivating people to do those things. What are they not good at? They're not good at building neurocognitive skills. It's not their fault. They just were never intended to be used that way. They're not good at building a helping relationship between one person and another. And ultimately, they're not good at helping people stay calm in the midst of frustration, as we talked about. There's very clear research, thousands of studies that have shown beyond the shadow of a doubt, that when you use a tangible external reinforcer, reward to try to get somebody to do something, there's a strong negative correlation with the development
它们擅长提醒人们对他们的期望是什么，什么是对的，什么是错的，它们擅长激励人们做这些事情。它们不擅长什么？它们不擅长建立神经认知技能。这不是它们的错。它们本来就不是为了这种用途而设计的。它们不擅长在一个人和另一个人之间建立互助关系。归根结底，正如我们所讨论的，它们不擅长帮助人们在沮丧中保持冷静。有非常明确的研究，数以千计的研究毫无疑问地表明，当你使用切实的外在强化物、奖励来试图让某人做某事时，与发展的过程存在强烈的负相关关系
of intrinsic driver motivation. In other words, the more we try to motivate somebody with something externally, we eat away at that person's internal drive. I'm wondering when you step back and look at this body of work, Stuart, obviously you're working with individual patients, you have individual case studies. But I think you're making in some ways perhaps even a larger moral argument here about how we need to interact with others. Talk about that bigger picture. What do you see about the benefits of this approach versus the conventional approach, you know, writ large? Well, it is really a moral argument, but it's a scientifically based one.
内在动力驱动力。换句话-说，我们越是用外在的东西去激励某人，我们就在侵蚀那个人的内在动力。我想知道，当你退一步来看待这项工作时，斯图尔特，显然你在与个别患者合作，你有单独的案例研究。但我认为你甚至在某种程度上提出了一个更大的道德论点，关于我们需要如何与他人互动。谈谈那个更大的图景。与传统方法相比，你如何看待这种方法的优势？嗯，这确实是一个道德论点，但它也是一个基于科学的论点。
You know, when I say people do well if they can, people say, well, that's a very nice philosophy. I said, well, it may be an empathic and compassionate one, but it is also one rooted in science. in understanding the brain. And it has enormous implications. When it comes to the human cost, when it comes to actual financial costs, you know, if we could rethink behavior, if we could move away from punitive interventions when people are struggling with skill instead of will, it could have dramatic implications in terms of billions of dollars of cost savings. and more importantly, human lives that are saved. So, yes, this is a, you know, this means something much larger. Stuart Ablon is a psychologist at Harvard Medical School.
你知道，当我说人们如果能做到就会做得很好时，人们会说，嗯，这是一个非常好的哲学。我说，嗯，这可能是一个富有同理心和同情心的哲学，但它也是植根于科学、对大脑的理解的哲学。它有着巨大的影响。当谈到人类的成本时，当谈到实际的财务成本时，你知道，如果我们能够重新思考行为，如果我们能够在人们在技能而非意志上挣扎时摆脱惩罚性干预，它可能会在数十亿美元的成本节省方面产生巨大影响，更重要的是，拯救了人的生命。所以，是的，这是一个，你知道，这意味着更宏大的事情。斯图尔特·阿布隆是哈佛医学院的心理学家。
He is the author of Changeable, How Collaborative Problem Solving Changes Lives at home, at school, and at work. Stuart Ablon, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was truly my pleasure. I really appreciate to having this conversation and being interested in our work. Thanks so much for sharing it. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
他是《可改变的：协作解决问题如何改变家庭、学校和工作中的生活》一书的作者。斯图尔特·阿布隆，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这真的是我的荣幸。我非常感谢能进行这次对话并对我们的工作感兴趣。非常感谢你分享它。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》传媒制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love Hidden Brain and want more of our work, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. It's where you'll find conversations and insights you won't hear anywhere else.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》并想了解我们的更多工作，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅《隐藏的大脑Plus》。在这里你会找到在其他任何地方都听不到的对话和见解。
Plus, you'll be playing a vital role in helping to fund the writing, research, and audio production that go into every episode of the show. To try Hidden Brain Plus with a free seven-day trial, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain. We truly appreciate your support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
另外，你将在资助每一期节目的写作、研究和音频制作方面发挥至关重要的作用。要通过七天免费试用来体验《隐藏的大脑Plus》，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com 顺斜杠 hidden brain。我们真心感谢您的支持。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。回头见。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。